já está valendo
Então tá começando agora mais um pode
que se chama mais um pode porque é só
mais um podcast né Realmente a gente
quer que as coisas sejam especiais e
sejam diferentes nosso meu tem um
diferencial não tem o meu é a mesma
luminárias mande fazer até no mesmo
lugar eu acho de todos os outros e aí a
gente vai proporcionar conteúdos
diferentes aqui com os nossos convidados
vão fazer de conta que você não sabe
quem é porque você não viu na thumb nem
ler o título sabe quem está aqui com a
gente hoje ela mesmo bagunçando a
divisão
olá oi gente
tudo bom Carol tudo bem Whindersson
agora tá tudo melhor agora mais calma
quantos dias foi assim quando você saiu
quantos dias foi tipo para dizer assim
ah não agora eu tô respirando hein nem
tô pensando nisso 24 horas por dia
acho que ainda estou num processo de
entanto é tentando
relaxar com tudo eu não sei se pode
falar se não puder retira depois mas
tipo quando a gente tava tentando entrar
em contato para falar o pessoal falava
assim ah não Ela ainda tá muito assim
não sei se ela vai porque ela ainda tá
muito cismada alguma coisa assim
o pessoal quando vai conversar é só
querendo furar a pessoa
que eu tomei conhecimento geral mesmo de
tudo depois de 10 dias que eu saí do
confinamento e assim que eu saí da casa
no dia seguinte já tinha uma equipe me
acompanhando para gravar meu doc
Então nem deu para similar primeiro para
tu primeiro para depois ir para outro
trabalho a galera já tava
ainda naquela casca da soberba para me
sentir menos acuada então não tinha
entendido muito bem Eu sabia que eu
havia errado dentro da casa mas eu não
entendi Quais foram os pontos mais
críticos desses 10 dias que tu foi
assistindo porque ainda minha equipe
minha família me privavam de assistir de
ter noção de tudo porque eu fiquei muito
abalada com a repercussão eu poderia ser
muita informação de uma pessoa
fazendo aos poucos Então demorou muito
depois de um mês ainda assim eu fui
caindo a ficha ainda hoje por exemplo eu
já tive
outras cenas que eu ainda não tinha
visto ainda tem situações porque tem que
ter tipo tempo hábil para ver as coisas
né porque tipo foram muitos dias né que
tu passou lá dentro
as minhas atitudes mas foi complicado
não ter um momento de descanso assim
sair assim lá então
ter uma equipe gravando a sua vida o seu
dia a dia depois de um confinamento
depois de você ter sido a mais odiada do
Brasil e às vezes você quer ter um papo
assim sincero com a pessoa e aí um monte
de gente aqui filmando o que quer né
porque é uma hora para aí depois começa
é uma hora as pessoas escolhendo o
momento da tua vida que que são vendidos
foi como se eu fosse uma coisa cada um
falava uma coisa na internet cada um
tinha um diagnóstico sobre a minha eu
não assisti o programa porque eu não sou
assim eu não assisto muita televisão em
geral assim ou reality gerava Não
assisto muito porque eu acho que quando
uma pessoa vai torcer não tem que torcer
cara torcer vai brincar brincadeira
inteira então então vamos brincar Então
vamos brincar e eu não sei essa pessoa
que eu durmo em horário de trocada então
eu perco as vezes estou querendo saber
quem vai sair amanhã perco a eliminação
Então para mim eu já vejo que é um caso
perdido eu não assisto essas coisas só
que o Twitter confia pelo cu da gente as
coisas que a gente não tá nem aí
querendo ver monte de gente um programa
é um sucesso né muita gente assista o
programa e um monte de gente falando
todas as suas opiniões e todas as
paradas e tudo mais e aí eu eu teve um
episódio do que a galera falava de
xenofobia né Então nesse dia do episódio
como qualquer uma pessoa eu entrei no
Twitter vi um vídeo lá cortado um
pedacinho dizendo ela disse isso fez
isso e pá pá aí eu olhei o vídeo e a
legenda aí está fiquei zangado com a
Carol fui lá no Instagram na Carol dei
um fora na Carol porque eu me dou muito
por coisa de de
Nordeste assim sabe falando qualquer
coisa
eu já me dou muito assim entendeu Aí aí
os dias foram passando né e tudo mais e
eu vendo pessoal não sei porque quando
sair vai pegar na pedra quando sair vou
pegar de pau quando sair vai fazer isso
quando sair vai eu comecei a pensar
assim
como ser humano normal assim um
pouquinho parar e pensar 10 segundos
antes de entrar na onda da galera tá
ligado eu parei um pouquinho falei assim
cara se é real a história de fé se é
real a história de energia né se é real
a história de o que a gente deseja a
gente atrai que o pessoal fala você é o
que você sente você é o que você pensa
não é assim então cara se for verdade
isso tudo isso que eu tô vendo Twitter
aqui agora a galera odiando tipo Brasil
se unindo para odiar uma pessoa sofre
dessa pessoa vai sair de lá com outro
braço na barriga velho vai vai brotar
uma coisa assim diferente um uma gosma
vai sair de dentro porque [ __ ] é muito
desejo ruim eu pensava assim não pô não
eu não vou participar dessa parada tá
ligado eles Aproveite a atitude lá
porque eu também como qualquer pessoa eu
entrei e vi um pedaço né E aí depois eu
fiquei
vendo que tava todo mundo entrando numa
consciência de odiar uma pessoa
pode mesmo direcionado
aí eu comecei a achar que isso não é não
é bom em nenhum cenário e nenhum cenário
isso é legal a gente vê que a atitude
dessas pessoas acabam sendo piores do
que a minha dentro da casa e que elas
estejam tão doentes quanto eu até mais
porque ali naquele momento eu tava
amarga eu tava cheia de questões
pessoais minhas e ninguém tem culpa do
estado que entrou tu tava bem eu acho
que não porque há dois anos eu já tava
sentindo uma certa aflição e uma vontade
de não fazer nada eu acho que isso aí é
sabe porque
sou psicólogo não sei não mas assim eu
também já passei tantas questões na
minha cabeça que tanta gente fala para
mim assim nossa mas você tem isso você
tem aquilo você o Brasil ama você as
pessoas gostam de você aí eu falei assim
pô mas pode não gostar qualquer dia
desses tá ligado pode não gostar porque
todo mundo é gostado um tempo tá ligado
entendeu Tipo
todos os pilotos de avião são muito bons
Eles são muito [ __ ] mas tem uns que fica
triste e joga o avião em outro lugar pô
tá ligado Ele é uma pessoa normal igual
a qualquer pessoa então então tipo assim
eu acho que um pouco disso aí que isso
tava passando a de entrar era a mesma
coisa que às vezes eu passo essa parada
de tipo é aqui então é isso aqui então
tipo assim Ah então é eu cheguei aqui aí
tipo eu posso mandar em outras pessoas e
eles fazem umas coisas para mim eu pago
eles é assim então tá ligado Às vezes a
gente se auto sabota e às vezes o nosso
interior quer falar alguma coisa que a
gente não tá ouvindo
e eu pude perceber depois que eu sair do
confinamento que eu tava cheia de
questões mal resolvidas E aí o problema
foi que tipo assim tu foi para um lugar
mais vigiado do Brasil no momento das
duas questões mais resolvidas
eu fui expor minhas feridas camadas
cinzas no programa Mais vigiado do
Brasil
vamos tipo botar numa situação que
aconteceu lá dentro pega alguma situação
assim que aconteceu lá dentro que tu
sabe que tinha um pé
um pé assim de uma coisa mal resolvida
na tua cabeça aqui fora assim por
exemplo tem a questão da minha mania de
organização
quando eu tava ali na casa e eu notei
que
isso ia ser um problema porque as coisas
não ficava organizada não ficava
organizadas E aí eu pensei nossa eu acho
que eu vou me irritar com isso aí tinha
uma outra questão que ia me sentir
insegura porque ali naquele momento na
minha cabeça eu pensava eu tô no jogo Eu
preciso jogar aqui a gente precisar aqui
tentar relações Então você fala com uma
pessoa essa pessoa te fala uma coisa
você entende outra você passa outra isso
foi visível com todos os participantes
da casa e aí eu ficava numa situação que
eu me sentia pirada sabe pirada paranoia
mesmo paranoia com tudo inclusive com a
minha participação ali dentro
E aí tu começa também a ficar
porque tem o fator isolamento né que a
galera não bota aqui fora é o fator
isolamento você tá fechado com a galera
entendeu uma coisa que eu percebi Talvez
uma leitura que seja até sei lá dolorosa
mas assim quando o Lucas saiu pegou as
coisas dele saiu né quero uma das coisas
que também chegou para mim eu não
assisto mais uma das coisas que lá no
Twitter o dia inteiro a galera falando a
mesma coisa então quem não viu de manhã
nem meio-dia nem a tarde vem à noite é
assim é difícil você não vê e aí você vê
vários psiquiatra dando opinião vários
médico muito complicado Várias Vários tá
ligado várias paradas teve um até um que
eu fiz eu falei assim gente
eu sei que tem vários psiquiatras
psicólogo dando seus lados mas para mim
eu vi que um cabra bebeu
se passando limite fala umas bosta isso
na vida real no outro dia você dá um
caldo de ovo para pessoa tá ligado e
fala Opa meu irmão Ei ontem foi você deu
o show tá ligado tá ligado E aí lá
dentro Eu falei assim mas parece que a
galera não
tá afim de acolher eu bebo tá ligado
Tipo assim parece que a situação era
para ser uma situação típica de uma
sociedade qualquer entendeu pessoas que
bebem e passam do limite isso acontece
né Tipo você não odeia um estilo seu
porque eles ficam bêbado no final do ano
é normal ele sempre ficam várias
entendeu então tipo assim quando eu vi o
que aconteceu eu era para alguém estar
de manhã sei lá dando um café para ele
ele falou assim tá melhor porque [ __ ]
tu ficou very crazy ontem então acho que
o cara foi legal nas atitude do cara
também mas tipo ele tava muito louco
entendeu então tipo assim uma vida
normal na vida real todo mundo ia falar
tipo ontem você louquinho só que todo
mundo é então aí vem o fator o jogo que
você disse tem que jogar né então tipo
de Qual atitude tomar se aquilo vai
interferir e sabe o que que eu senti
naquele momento que tipo assim aquilo
ali era como se fosse uma mini saciedade
né onde tinha uma pessoa que mandava uma
pessoa que uma pessoa que era mais
tranquila uma pessoa que era mais da da
do sertanejo né que a galera vai mais
para um ladinho assim você vai vendo que
essas coisinhas vão tomando cada um no
seu ladinho assim sabe E aí quando
quando o Lucas saiu
eu vi como se nessa mini sociedade ele
tivesse tipo se suicidado
porque
as pessoas que ficam dentro não sabem o
que aconteceu depois que ele passou por
Depois da porta entendeu e acaba que
tipo por uns dias
você realmente aí você vê que a galera
fica um pouco de luto por um tempo e aí
depois
é esquecido tipo como qualquer sociedade
tá ligado só que ele era uma menina
sociedadezinha de pessoas pequenas
entendeu às vezes eu vejo isso no meu
bairro também tá ligado às vezes eu sei
quem é o confusão do meu bairro sei quem
é eu sei quem é o menino que passa
correndo aqui sempre faz um negócio
entendeu eu é uma mini sociedade Aí
naquele momento eu vi como tipo assim
[ __ ] o cara saiu Saiu alguém tinha
que ter conversado um pouquinho com ele
mas entendeu
da Bondade faltou caridade empatia ali
sabe foi um bateu no EGO de todo mundo
quando chegou ali aí eu parei de parei
de
consumir no twitter também tipo peguei a
palavra botei ali tirei um pouco que eu
já tava me sentindo meio estranho sabe
se sentiu um pouco estranho assim quando
você vê você acorda e tá todo mundo
falando porque [ __ ] aí ontem teve a
festa e aí vi tudo Conquista não sei
quem papapa e acorda de manhã tá todo
mundo dizendo a vi tudo falou isso pá
pouca e isso isso aí fica todo mundo
falando a mesma coisa a mesma coisa eu
falei assim não pera aí eu vou o cara
saiu ontem eu vou
vou dar um time desse negócio aqui assim
as coisas lá dentro elas ficam todas
diferentes então você acha que é uma
coisa é outra não tem muito como e não
tem muito o que fazer não ser ficar
dando uma conspiradinha né Será que
Fulano tá será que é né para você não
isso é uma coisa muito curiosa porque as
pessoas aqui fora ficam julgando porque
Fulano falou de ciclano lá dentro mas o
game é esse Você precisa que tentar as
relações então não dá para você não
falar de voto porque tipo enquanto você
tá Se você tipo curtir a casa tem outra
pessoa que tá articulando né então tipo
você precisa estar articulando também
você fica naquela insegurança ela Poxa
mas como é que tá ali aquela pessoa tá
do meu lado é meu aliado ou não é então
tem pessoas lá dentro que fica muito
carentes tem as pessoas que ficam mais
ácidas amargas que foi meu caso tem
pessoas que ficam mais
dorminhocas tu viu a Luna quando tu saiu
e ela é como é dentro fora ou ela também
se vê se viu diferente
foi uma a gente ficou no telefone
Conversando a gente tá vendo é um
experimento Pô isso é um experimento
científico estudado ela é leve ela é
doce e ali também ela teve gatilhos né
que tiveram válvulas ali que acabou
despertando umas coisas nela assim como
em mim também mas o meu estado de
agressividade lá dentro não Ninguém tem
culpa sabe eu reconheço isso mas eu já
entrei na casa com um pouco eu entendo
porque por exemplo assim cara sendo bem
sincero tipo já teve uma situação no
Ceará
que que houve como se fosse tipo um
campo de concentração tá ligado onde as
pessoas mandava os pobre Para Morrer
tipo estava morrendo nas ruas falava
tira daqui Porque aqui fica feia a
galera chegar a pessoa tá morrendo na
rua então bota para morrer por lá
entendeu morria tipo 200 mil cearense tá
ligado Então vinha nordestino aqui para
São Paulo os imigrantes e aí eles
construíam tudo que todo mundo anda toda
calçada todo prédio antigo aqui é de
imigrante então o cara chega para mim
fala alguma coisa de Nordeste Nordestino
eu fico possesso fico muito puto tá
ligado eu saio de mim um pouco então eu
eu tava até falando para os amigos meu
assim cara se o meu povo
sofresse todo e tudo aquilo que o povo
da Carol sofrer eu ia andar 100%
com pistola todo tempo toda hora Bom dia
[ __ ] Bom dia é o [ __ ] era toda hora
assim entendeu então tipo assim quando
você de gatilho a primeira coisa que me
vem na minha cabeça é alguém falar
alguma coisa de Nordeste na hora assim
eu já venho aqui sabe teve um cara
também que me convidou para ele podcast
aí uma parada e tudo mais e um dia
desses ele falava que falou que são
Paulo sustentava o Nordeste e aí tipo eu
não quis saber nem um pingo do contexto
uma desse cara chupar o pau de de quem
ele visse pela sério eu fiquei tão
postaste essa parada que eu consegui
entender tipo uma hora que você
tem um gatilho e ainda mais quem tem
vários gatilho né porque são vários
gatilhos
assim quando quando
o pessoal falava
e a Carol com carinho tava no lugar tava
conversando tal e acaba com carinho Aí
eu falava Ah cara tá lá né tá lá no Big
Brother saiu
ainda não não tá lá não sei que tudo
mais aí eu aí eu falei assim mais cara
vê tipo como
Como tudo tem história e tudo tem
contexto
Eu por exemplo eu sou um cara que eu fui
crente 10 anos 10 anos da minha vida foi
evangélico uma igreja tão boa todinho
Bíblia
[Música]
o crente rápido ligeiro
social e tal e ia era cliente 10 anos
sabe aí Eu segui as coisas assim
direitinho mesmo tudo que falava pastor
dizia eu disseram Você não viu que o
pastor disse rapaz misericórdia
misericórdia eu era irmão misericórdia
irmão entendeu falava meu Deus eu era
assim eu era uma pessoa desse jeito aí e
aí eu
tinha um maior preconceito com
homossexual tem noção não tinha o maior
preconceito maior preconceito eu tinha
um preconceito que eu não gostar de
falar sobre culto não tem noção
e não tem nem a ver uma coisa com a
outra você não pode ligar
homossexualidade não tem a ver uma coisa
com a outra deu hoje eu tenho essa noção
mas antigamente a minha noção era tão
ridícula sim que eu eu não queria
conversar sobre um negócio que pudesse
lembrar o que tem a ver uma coisa com a
outra entendeu E aí eu achei eu tive um
tempo da minha vida
eu tive que fazer uma cirurgia no cu
cara
a vida me trouxe até eu ter que abrir
minhas pernas dentro de um lugar com
várias pessoas e eu dormi e as pessoas
chegando para me operar eu com as pernas
abertas assim falando meu Deus a
enfermeira entrando várias enfermeira e
eu apagando e eu não
aí operou e fez tudo isso
é só um pedaço da minha história Isso é
uma parte do meu corpo então tipo quando
alguém chegar para mim falar assim ó
você não sabe que eu passei você não
sabe o que que o índice passou nessa
vida que que o índios passou na vida
tudo meu amigo tudo entendeu então tipo
assim quando o pessoal te tava querendo
te detonar e fazer o que queria fazer
que estavam dizendo que queria fazer ai
que quando sair eu vou fazer isso eu vou
fazer aquilo dentro de mim eu só
esperava alguém dizer alguém tem um
pouquinho de compaixão perto de mim
primeiro para eu não sei a primeira
pessoa logo porque eu eu comecei a achar
estranho que em todo lugar falava assim
gente espera aí vamos parar com essa
Vamos parar com essa conversa não eu
ficava esperando alguém falar e quando
alguém falava assim tipo assim ó ah cara
mas não é bom falar nada dela porque
ninguém sabe o que ela passou quando
falava ninguém sabe o que ela passou
dentro de mim e fala assim ninguém sabe
o que ela passou
ela passou tudo mano tudo é muita coisa
meu amigo é muita coisa na vida de uma
pessoa se essa aqui foi história do meu
corpo e mudou tanto tudo que mudou
imagina um
a história de uma pessoa imagina a
história de uma pessoa que nem tu assim
é ruim ficar é ruim quando a gente
percebe que
nossas falhas acabam criando um rótulo e
a gente é reduzido
a um capítulo desse livro eu falo que eu
sou um livro somos é como se fossemos
livros né então a gente não tem como
reduzir
resumir a história de um livro vendo só
um capítulo você tem que entender o que
tem antes daquele Capítulo e o que vem
depois contexto é sempre muito
importante exatamente eu super reconheço
meus erros Óbvio Mas eu também tô
naquele processo de não me detestar de
não me reprovar eu não posso ser a
pessoa que vai fazer isso comigo meu
Deus eu fiquei muito triste porque é eu
fiquei aí vendo uma galera fazendo
diagnóstico sabe eu falando com um
especialista perguntando eu sou isso que
tão falando me chamaram de psicopata
sociopata narcisista
eu fiquei assim eu falei meu Deus mas
por que que eu fiquei desse jeito nessa
cena não me reconheço nessa eu já me
reconheço que tem um lance de primeiro
que para chegar eu cheguei não foi fácil
Óbvio isso é até clichê mas é a história
de muita gente é a nossa história então
eu precisei ter curso mais firme em
alguma situação
não tem isso pronto É isso aí só faltava
isso aí e sabe que às vezes esse é um
medo que eu tenho
não não de estragar tudo não tenho medo
de estragar tudo tá ligado mas por
exemplo eu sou um ser humano normal né
você é um ser humano normal apesar da
pessoa da Galera achar que
que quando a gente entra num carro
alguma coisa
irada dentro acontece quando acontece
nada tipo o motorista sai andando a
gente fica mexendo no celular e aí
alguém fala
E aí
sei lá e manda um GIF engraçado tipo
igual uma pessoa normal entendeu então
eu penso tipo assim quando eu via Quando
eu via quando você tava agindo daquele
jeito
eu ficava assim cara às vezes eu tenho
medo de eu estar desse jeito aí e não
não tá me ligando também porque ela só
não tá se ligando eu sei que ela não é
assim eu conversei com ela eu já vi ela
várias vezes ela não é desse jeito aí
não mas assim
ela não tá se ligando
e aí eu pensava assim às vezes eu ficava
assim [ __ ] Será que eu tô sendo uma
pessoa legal tô de boa eu tô tipo
viajando achando que eu tô arrasando tá
ligado teve quando tu ver aquela parte
que tu falar que tu fala se não gostou
me bota no paredão
[Risadas]
é sério eu ficava assim quando eu vi que
esse momento virou meme Eu não entendi
nada e ainda tinha pessoas falando que
foi uma jogada de marketing porque tudo
as pessoas acham que eu tô pagando para
fazer ou tem algum ponto no meu ouvido
acredito em nada cada um cresceu a
realidade da sua cabeça e chegou um
ponto que assim falei gente tô sem moral
as pessoas não acreditam em mim por
causa de um erro Eles não conseguem
enxergar mais nada
do que a genuína em mim Eles não
conseguem acreditar em nada ou porque
preferem odiar continuar me odiando
porque é confortável para aliviar a
frustração deles mesmos ou porque
não conseguem entender que eu sou um ser
humano que eu tenho minhas camadas e uma
das minhas camadas foram expostas não
reality show mas se colocar uma câmera
na casa de todo mundo todo mundo vai ter
um momento de cancelamento
a gente se uma pessoa normal mesmo e é
isso que eu tava falando tipo eu sou uma
pessoa normal ela fala assim ah mas o
povo as pessoas gostam de você eu falo é
deixa eu deixa eu atropelar um cachorro
sem querer Deixa eu fazer alguma coisa
que um ser humano normal faz do tipo sei
lá tô aqui e aconteceu uma eventualidade
uma parada tá ligado Tipo qualquer coisa
e aí tudo pode mudar todo o cenário pode
mudar toda a realidade pode mudar tudo
que você teve várias ideias passou
várias noites pensando e tentando dar a
sua cara o projeto um negócio né porque
a gente tá sempre assim não bota tudo
por água abaixo você fala meu Deus um
surto emocional desequilíbrio emocional
e comportamental né que eu tive ali
eu falei caramba não que eu não tenha
aquele temperamento Não precisei ser
daquele jeito aqui fora mas não com
aquela intensidade num momento que
desnecessário por exemplo ali não
precisava não precisava sabe eu
reconheço que não precisava mas
reconheço também que faz parte de mim
aquilo ali também faz parte da minha
camada Então eu preciso tratar essa
parte para conseguir
lidar com frustrações eu nunca tinha
parado para pensar
é porque tipo você quando tá ali numa
situação nacional e aí você fica tipo
meio que todo mundo meio que de seca
todo ato seu tá ligado toda fala e tudo
a galera meio que dá uma de secadinha
que se acontecesse com qualquer pessoa
na rua
a gente ia ver muito mais coisa talvez
ainda que não chegou um momento que nas
redes as pessoas faziam montagem com o
rosto de outros participantes quando
eles tinham atitudes humanas como ciúmes
fazer
intriguinha tirar satisfação então
parecia que todas essas atitudes foi fui
eu que inventei é como se ninguém mais
os ciúmes nunca ninguém teve ciúmes a
Carol inventou o ciúmes Carol inventou a
discórdia Então dentro de um jogo de um
Reality é disso que a gente sobrevive lá
dentro senão você pode ir para o paredão
senão você pode perder uma prova Tem
várias coisas várias questões não dá
para misturar com que tá aqui fora então
assim eu o que se o que se planta se
colhe No meu caso eu acho que a colheita
tá sendo
muito grande perto do que Eu Plantei
sabe então vem aquele sentimento de sim
eu reconheço que errei e ao mesmo tempo
de Poxa mas Precisava tudo isso a
proporção é muito grande né E só comigo
sabe não eu não desejo isso que eu
passei tô passando para ninguém mas eu
acho que vale a reflexão também nem eu
quando eu
[Música]
quando eu assim quando eu tenho um
período que eu fico ruim mal
esse momento é um momento que eu fico
todo tempo pensando assim eu queria eu
queria lembrar de como é quando você tá
feliz eu queria lembrar de como é quando
você tá feliz sabe fica naquele coisa
quando eu tô assim bem Bad assim não
consigo sair do fundo do poço entendeu
Aí eu penso assim como é que a pessoa
consegue desejar isso para alguém quando
você tá muito mal você sabe a sensação
de estar mal sabe é corporal né É não é
só Mental é corporal Assim você fica
meio
você fica meio assim sabe para dentro
você fica é para dentro de você fica
meio parece que você vai sumir para
dentro
e aí
Nossa eu não quero não que as pessoas
paciência então não entrei na na onda da
galera não entrei na brincadeira porque
a maioria dessas pessoas que eu via
porque todo mundo que eu seguia tava
assistindo e tava comentando todo mundo
sem exceção todas as pessoas que eu
cheguei tava comentando e tava lá
metendo o pau falando normal e tudo mais
e tudo mais e as mesmas pessoas que fala
de apatia empatia e foi aí que eu
comecei a pegar Carol assim te falando
de sinceridade um pouquinho de nojo
dessa palavra empatia porque assim é uma
palavra até muito bonita me lembra
alguma coisa de sangue empatia nela uma
coisa de alguma coisa de doação né sei
lá me lembra É que eu gosto de associar
as palavras
Mas tipo tem palavra caixa bonita
estelionatário eu acho lindo
mas o que um estágio natário Faz é feita
mas a palavra
Nossa gostosinho queria muito
Whindersson um grande estelionatário do
Brasil eu queria muito ser mas só que o
estelionatário eh rouba cartão dos
outros aí eu não quero mais ser entendeu
mas a palavra é bonita a palavra é legal
aí é a palavra empatia nós tem uma
palavra até legal até bonita só que tipo
assim hoje em dia eu não sei o que que é
que a galera Pega umas palavras joga na
roda e passa um tempo a palavra não tem
sentido mais ela não ela é só uma
palavra mesmo igual tipo mesa cadeira tá
ligado e a gente comenta É
eu vi pessoas comentando vamos ter mais
empatia com a Carol Aí uma outra pessoa
comenta
vamos ter mais empatia com ela que não
teve a empatia Então qual é o papel da
empatia ela só é para quem tem e quem
não tem como é que a gente lida com um
momento uma situação que a pessoa tá num
estado de nervo onde a empatia falta
você ignora essa pessoa ou você
contagia ela com a empatia E aí é mais
uma pessoa para entender a empatia então
às vezes a empatia tá julgando a empatia
e falta empatia da própria empatia é a
corrente da empatia e o que que é empate
empatia é você se colocar no lugar
das pessoas da situação não de uma
pessoa da situação entendeu porque você
não bota só de uma pessoa porque toda
situação é que é uma situação de
conversa de conflito tem mais gente né
mas você não pode ter empatia por uma
pessoa escolher quem é a pessoa que você
tem empatia e ter você tem que ter
empatia pelo filho da Carol pela mãe tá
ligado do Lucas Penteado também por ele
pelos amigos
tudo entendeu tá ligado então tipo assim
agora eu tenho empatia com o público que
me odeia isso você tem entendeu porque o
público que lhe odeia você já não tá
levando mais com eu odeio eles você tá
levando porque eu entendo porque que
eles estão assim a empatia é isso se
vocês colocaram eu entendo que eu eu
protagonizei cenas ali
totalmente desgostosas sabe o que causa
aflição então eu entendo a raiva deles
por mim e a gente que tá nessa posição
de figura pública a gente não pode errar
e isso é torturante também para gente
porque é o tempo inteiro sendo perfeito
ou criando uma vida dupla então eu tenho
a vida mais reservada e a vida artista e
ali É como se eu tivesse misturado
cagado com tudo entendeu É como se eu
tivesse me jogado fora me abandonado
então comecei a avaliar isso eu tô com
problema de auto amor qual é o problema
porque eu entrei no reality e porque eu
agir dessa forma esquecendo meus
princípios meu respeito respeito pelo
próximo e quando a gente trata as
pessoas assim é porque a gente tá sem
sem amor para si mesmo né então quando a
gente não se ama a gente trata o outro
mal
então tipo como se fosse para ti uma
outra pessoa
não Carol com cá Sou Eu também mas é um
Alter Ego é uma coisa mais firme mais
poderosa é como se ela não deixasse Que
a Carolina
e Tomás
Caroline
tô tomando tô tomando gente
também bota no paredão qualquer coisa me
bota no paredão que eu tenho na carreira
bem bonita lá fora entendeu eu falo
gente e o povo Cadê a carreira dela
[Risadas]
ai que horror eu não posso me odiar eu
me perdoo eu me perdoo mas qualquer
coisa me bota na tua oração
qualquer coisa faz uma oração que eu
tinha uma carreira bem bonita aqui fora
Ai meu Deus eu tô rindo mais do que eu
assisti show de stand up no Netflix
minha língua não é mais um chicote hoje
em dia hoje já já tá diferente né é
cortei né já tá com gírias nordestinas
agora
eu tô num processo que eu tenho que
entender
tu ficou
se vendo e aí tu ficava dizendo assim
tipo
aqui aqui eu entendo que foi isso era
tipo assim sim tinha cenas que eu falava
porque eu fiz isso porque hoje dessa
forma não me reconheço e tem cenas que
eu olho e falo tá aqui eu me reconheço
então que tem que brincar é a galera não
entendeu sim tem essas partes também
juntou com uma hora que eu falei uma
merda aí ficou parecendo que eu tô mas
não é na verdade eu sou dessa forma
então tem cenas que realmente eu me
passei tem outras que não é naquele Tom
que foi replicado nas redes sociais
então eu sempre fui muito brincalhona
Debochada de falar fazendo assim sempre
brinquei com isso mas não tão leve de
brincadeira e lá dentro também eu eu me
sentia asfixiada pelos meus próprios
pensamentos então aqui fora as pessoas
começaram a brincar algumas atitudes que
tinha dentro da casa com vídeos antigos
onde eu falava de filmes favoritos do
momento que eu tava então eu falei sobre
o fragmentado num desses vídeos de sei
lá quanto tempo atrás e aí as pessoas
Olha Ela é psicopata ela é fragmentada
também aí eu vi um vídeo que eu tô no
quarto com outro participante eu começo
a falar desse jeito aqui e eu fico
sussurrando falando gente
E aí as pessoas ficam Nossa olha lá a
outra pessoa é e acontece que as pessoas
esquecem que eu sou artista é artista
todo artista Tem Uma Mente criativa e eu
gosto muito de brincar e de fazer
personagens isso não tá ligado
então beleza então
eu tenho amigos que são assim eu faço
assim tipo ah tá demorando aqui a gravar
o negócio da propaganda eu falo
mas já são duas
urina
se você tá num reality as pessoas vão
analisavam falar que você tem múltiplas
personalidades no meu caso não é isso
já tô vendo com especialista né gente
falar galera tá aqui mas não é só uma
criativa
Eu tenho esse dois lados que é o lado
melancólico um lado mais e o lado mais
sarcástico debochado então eu tiro sarro
de mim mesma Já tô no nível que assim já
consigo tirar onda com a minha cara fala
não mas é uma ridícula entrou lá dentro
se achando toda cagada no rolê achando
que tava arrasando ai vai querida eu
falo comigo mesmo eu falo querida
e eu fiquei muito brava quando eu vi eu
ai não sei o quê Falei meu Deus aí tem
um outro VT que eu falo Desculpe
desculpe por ser debochada
e eu sempre falei assim desse jeito
brincando com as minhas amigas sabe
tirando uma onda e ali parece que eu sou
daquele jeito mas também sou no meu
estado de humor não quer dizer que não
seja um pouquinho às vezes brincando né
uma coisa que tá ali e outra sou uma
mulher
que já tá um bom tempo fazendo shows e
trabalhando com TV imagem e público
então assim não querem que eu diga que
eu tenho uma carreira ou que eu sou
poderosa é como se
a gente não pudesse falar sobre isso É
como se eu não pudesse achar isso sabe
então são várias questões que eu fui
levantando analisando os vídeos de
vários erros meus e vários erros do
público também tá se resolver Porque
tipo quem quem falou de você hoje não tá
nem aí eles não tão preocupados
elas querem que eu continue forte para
continuar me batendo então bateram tão
forte em mim justamente por ser Carol
com K ai a poderosa encheu a boca para
dizer que tem uma carreira bem bonita
Então vamos acabar com ela e aí quando
bate bate tá lá no chão agora levanta
vai vida que segue empatia vem cá vou te
acolher depois a gente bater um monte
vou te acolher para poder usar hashtag
empatia dizer que eu estava aqui
fique forte que é para te bater então
tem esse universo sádico eu reconheço
também pitadas de sadismo no meu
comportamento dentro da casa e isso tá
muito ligado em segurança tá muito
ligado à falta de auto-amor então será
que esse povo que tá me odiando e faz
questão de me odiar não não também não
tá com uma questão mal resolvida não
espelhada né o que acontece muito isso
também a galera espelha em você sim
atitudes que ela quer que você tenha Só
que você é você e aí às vezes você tem
as atitudes que a pessoa não teria
porque você não é ela Você é você mesmo
entendeu então às vezes a pessoa espelho
em você a bondade que elas pensam sim
aquelas vezes elas acham que elas são
muito benevolente as Madre Teresa E aí
elas vão lá
tem que ver que tudo tem dois lados e o
lance da do acolhimento da empatia ele
tá ligado
ao sentimento atitude de caridade né que
as pessoas confundem caridade só como
você dá uma esmola dá alguma coisa tá
muito ligada a paciência também a você
entender o processo do outro me faltou
isso já levantei essa questão assim
também perto de roda de amigo a galera
não tá nem aí para isso não já parei
para prestar atenção Já levantei assim
de tipo gente mas assim Jesus a galera
agora vai vir você vem gente
de fé em Deus Cristo aí tipo não julgue
é tipo
é agora a hora é agora a hora de usar
não é quando é que vocês quer usar é
depois quando uma pessoa erra você vai
apanhar lá ela até ela cometer outros
erros até consigo mesmo de tristeza ou
contagiar ela com o Real Espírito de
Deus que é o amor o respeito e ter mais
uma pessoa para espalhar essa ideia não
menos uma por isso que eu sou contra o
cancelamento Eu nunca fiz parte dessa
dessa corrente de cancelamento nunca
levei a sério isso porque eu acho que é
uma coisa muito séria as pessoas que
desejam anular a outra pessoa elas são
pessoas que já se anularam a muito tempo
e anularam a possibilidade de ser
empáticos e espalhar o verdadeiro amor
então assim para mim no meu caso eu
ainda tô um pouco
a batida balada com as coisas que
passaram para muita gente foi só um
surto coletivo minha participação no
reality para muita gente acham que eu
sou uma louca que faço teatro e estou
inventando vários personagens e para
outras pessoas elas conseguem entender
que eu cometi esse deslize
comportamental emocional e eu tô
disposta a me tornar uma pessoa melhor
mas como tratando essas camadas então
convido as pessoas que estão com ódio
dentro do coração assim
chegarem também e se reconhecerem nos
meus erros porque eu sou ser humano
Então vamos todo mundo se tratar
entendeu a Carol vai se tratar assim eu
vou mas e vocês também vão porque todo
mundo precisa né a conta que ela está
dando de uma coisa que tu nem sabia nem
o que era que ela tava dizendo porque
tipo tem momentos específicos que as
pessoas lembram que eu acho que é mais
ou menos parecido com uma conta aí velho
quando eu fui gravar o programa da Ana
Maria foi já no dia seguinte que eu saí
do confinamento e eu tinha dormido só 40
minutos cochilado Então tava ali antes
de dormir era o quê conversando Toda
hora minha mãe é muito preocupada
perguntando se eu tava bem e eu e eu
tava ela fala que eu tava em estado de
choque porque eu não
aparentava
eu falava não tudo bem só que eu não
tava tendo até acesso às redes então eu
não ainda não conseguia eles estavam me
segurando assim né E aí eu já tava com
vergonha de estar ali no programa e
tentando manter a simpatia o respeito
ali pelo programa falar com Ana Maria
então não dava para chegar tipo ah
mestre puxando sabe e ainda tava
tentando entender o que estava
acontecendo E aí ela comentou sobre
xenofobia
sobre o sotaque da Juliet na hora eu
fiquei tentando assimilar do que que ela
estava falando qual foi esse momento
e eu só pensava não se justifica Carol
que isso tudo vai piorar E aí eu falo
tava sentindo que o negócio tava maior
do que o ângulo maior eu falei meu Deus
como é que eu vou falar Não não sou
xenofóbica quando no momento as pessoas
querem mais é que você
se exploda qualquer coisa que eu falasse
ali ninguém ia dar razão eu só fico
tensa e eu faço isso de tensa Tipo o que
aconteceu eu falo não eu não tenho
problema com sotaque da Juliet e eu
tentando assim segurar o choro
mantendo um falando caramba que que
aconteceu porque lá dentro tá rolando
uma vidinha né que tá acontecendo assim
tal ninguém tá muito se ligando em
câmera que tipo assim ai esse momento
que acabou de acontecer foi gravado tá
ligado ninguém pensa nisso né É mais ou
menos Tipo que acontece comigo quando
alguém chega comigo gosta de um vídeo
muito antigo tem um tipo 400 vídeos no
meu canal o cara gosta de um vídeo tipo
número 82 aí ele gosta de uma frase que
eu falei no vídeo ele chega para mim e
fala e aí o índice o teu avô e se aquilo
aí eu fico
que qual foi aí fala não é aquele vídeo
tem um momento gravado que tipo a galera
que tá aqui fora tá vendo E analisando
esse negócio assim tipo Olha a bolsa ali
tá aberta na Fulano tá dormindo e tá
escutando a outra tá se maquiando tá
escutando ali o negócio Olha tá todo
mundo vendo E vocês estão conversando
normal como duas pessoas assim depois eu
entendi depois eu falei nossa eu fui
infeliz na minha colocação na hora que
eu fui falar da minha cidade para não
ter que usar uma palavra
como reservado na hora eu usei outra
palavra educado e isso Acabou ferindo
muitos nordestinos mas não saiu nenhum
momento da minha boca que eu não tenho
respeito por nordestino pelo nordeste ou
que eu acho que não é um povo educado o
que eu falei foi que eu no meu caso era
mais fresca para não ter que usar esta
palavra falar reservado ou fresca eu
acabei falando uma outra fui feliz na
minha colocação Mas nenhum momento eu
tava com isso por isso eu não entendia
na hora que Ana Maria falava porque eu
não tive essa intenção enquanto falava
das outras situações com outros
participantes eu entendia porque eu me
vi na situação de fazer feiura mas nessa
especificamente não pois nessa Eu
entendi errado também que eu deixei de
seguir nessa não mas eu entendo eu
entendo assim como eu disse eu me dou
muito Nordeste falou um a Eu me dou
demais aí
nem procurar nem saber quem disse o que
que foi que hora foi com quem já foi lá
Nossa eu fiquei desesperada porque eu
falava assim meu Deus não foi isso e eu
queria fazer vídeo eu queria fazer uma
live e eu queria falar e eu nervosa eu
chorava e aí eu pensava meu Deus mas
esse público não tá vendo o público Tá
achando que é isso é porque não não sabe
da minha história não sabe que Jamais
seria isso jamais tanto que as minhas
músicas tem muitos elementos nordestinos
por conta da minha avó que a baiana e eu
então é que a minha avó fugiu para
Curitiba ela sofreu a violência
doméstica
então eu achava que o tom da minha pele
era um pouquinho mais desbotado que o
dela por eu ter nascido em Curitiba que
faz muito frio isso quando eu era
criança e aí Eu sempre tive esse
respeito até eu fiquei chateada de
verdade os meus melhores shows foram no
nordeste disparado e assim sempre tive
uma conexão muito gostosa com o público
então ali na hora isso me cortou assim
coração não sabia como
reagir e tiveram vários fake News eu
acho que é tipo como eu sinto tipo
Manaus tipo se alguém inventasse alguma
história minha
de Manaus e tipo Manaus é tipo um dos
lugares que eu faço shows mais irados
mais legais e tal e você fica nessa
cidade de querer se explicar né por uma
coisa que você me falou não fez mas aí
por causa desse Episódio
começaram a inventar fake News
aspas minhas tipo a Carol falou mal de
tal lugar só que não tinha vídeo disso
porque eu não falei E aí meu amigo que é
de BH chegou a comentar assim nossa tem
aspas aqui que de você falando mal de BH
que foi o primeiro lugar que eu fui
cantar que eu pisei fora de Curitiba
para fazer show e eu tenho um carinho
muito grande então eu fiquei assim
me sentindo Nossa galera quer destruir
de todos os lados
se as coisas fossem justas mesmo não
teria tomado essa proporção que eu acho
que assim ai é jogo fiz cagada no jogo
elimina ali acabou mas assim a apedrejar
já tão fazendo pior ainda muito além do
que da minha atitude lá dentro situação
de distúrbio emocional então é
complicado né mas
eu sei que Quem me conhece sabe que o
rolê é outro mas agora eu vou ter que
pena a para falar assim ó gente só de
boa tem o meu lado marrenta assim não é
à toa que eu comecei a cantar no rap
então não vou ficar falando ai sou santa
porque eu não sou entendeu mas eu não
quero que tentei maldade para ninguém na
minha vida então acredito na justiça
divina e isso acredito e as coisas vão
se acalmar Amém
as pessoas
achando graça em algumas situações Então
tinha gente que chegava e falava assim
olha que legal você é
muito famosa agora
Olha só
acho legal dessa forma né dessa forma né
ah olha que legal tem meme com a tua
cara
e eu Putz não sei se eu acho isso legal
porque
começar a fazer meme de uma situação de
uma frase
que eu gostei foi o único que eu gostei
mas eu achei esse Engraçado que era era
eu na era eu na capa da Toddy E aí tipo
assim a tal de trocou de boi
foi [ __ ] essa não foi não foi bom
não essa eu falei não foram foram
incisivos
[Risadas]
com a minha cara e bateu a foto tá
ligado Tipo eu acho engraçado aí ela vai
bate ela para e fala assim não espera aí
galera eu vou mandar aqui pra galera eu
acho muito engraçado assim também eu
ficava só chocada eu falava porque
porque eu tava um tempo de afastada das
redes quando eu saí e eu falei ué mas
Por que que estão revivendo essa cena um
milhão e 900 assim aí tu foi para 1.800
eu [ __ ] a galera tá deixando de
seguir ela velho aí foi uns 700 eu falei
assim não espera aí foi muito porque a
gente a gente quer dar um tempo para
maldade prestar atenção a gente quer dar
um tetra eu queria que você perdesse ali
uns r$ 100.000
tava mais quando for 200 foi nós 200 é
gente já hein
gente aí começou a passar tipo assim do
que eu tinha de teto para maldade não eu
teto para maldade era 100.000 seguidor
100.000 como é que ficou 1 milhão e
pouco ainda quando eu saí porque eu
pensei Nossa você toda cagada Mas é
porque tipo meio que a engrenagem roda a
engrenagem roda ele desce aí você sai e
você vira um homem falado a engrenagem
dá uma rodada você volta um pouquinho de
novo assim eu entendo muitas mensagens
legais assim Teve muitas de ódio Óbvio
mas muitas mensagens bacanas assim sabe
que era eu acordava de manhã já com uma
era uma sensação de uma bola de Halls ou
de gelo no meio do peito ansiedade pura
Eu imagino assim porque essa sensação
eu acho que ela fica mais aparente ainda
corporal ela fica mais aparente eu digo
isso pensando numa situação que eu tive
triste muito triste também e quando você
é pior quando você dorme e acorda o
problema ainda existe ele existe ele
pode aumentar ele tá crescendo enquanto
você tá acordando Tomando café ele tá
crescendo a gente falando mais coisa e
dizendo mais negócio então assim
conseguir perceber que eu me perdi de
mim da minha essência do meu propósito
há muito tempo é temos dois anos por aí
que eu já tinha percebido que eu não
tava bem teve um amigo meu que perguntou
para mim Carol fala que só para mim você
foi um personagem se quis fazer de
propósito falei eu adoraria poder dizer
assim foi um personagem E aí Pois é
gente essa porcentagem foi tudo aqui
deitada pela gente eu e a minha
Assessoria a gente queria sair com na
verdade com
99,89 mas a gente errou um pouquinho ali
eu tenho 17 Mas é isso obrigado
Brasil
é fantástico se fosse isso mas não foi
eu falei amigo não dele mas quem é
aquela foi aquela também sou eu é um
pedaço meu que tava aqui dentro e virou
aquilo lá dentro também estou tentando
entender o que gostou
Ah tem gente que gostou né Opa tem até
perfil enaltecendo cada pedaço cada
movimento feio feto do que eu tenho
feito sim sim gosto do da Vila da Vila
Aninha mesmo gosta da Vila Aninha coisas
que eu repúdio de atitudes minhas que
tem lá dentro a pessoa fala nossa que
linda a pessoa curtiu a versão que tu
não curte
e aí tem também pessoas que fala ai que
maravilhosa ela que chegue bem linda
vestida de Malévola bem fila anda na
cara do Brasil dando na cara de todo
mundo e eu assim
eu tô Caída no Chão nesse momento não
era isso que vocês queriam me ver
Tombada daí eu dou uma Tombada Nossa não
sabe no meu inbox porque eu fico
afastada das redes e teve uns dias dois
dias da semana que eu tinha acesso assim
eu consegui ver meu Deus
me mandando muitas mensagens lindas e
essas mesmas pessoas que me mandaram
oração e coração
em cima tinha mensagem salvas do início
do programa elas me detonando E aí no
final elas Nossa me perdoa tu fez parte
do arco evolutivo da pessoa
e gente falando Nossa eu te odiei muito
na casa mas depois que você saiu o ódio
diminuiu que quando você chega e o
presencial é muito diferente presencial
é outra coisa entendeu Tipo assim
quando quando a gente tava te chamando e
aí tava tinha toda essa questão de pai é
porque vai sair um documentário aí tem
que esperar isso e aqui não mas vamos e
a gente foi tentando se entender e tudo
mais eu fiquei nervoso um pouquinho
assim eu falei nossa não sei porque não
sei como você vai sentar aqui na minha
frente eu não sei depois tipo Você
também devia pensar a mesma coisa de mim
tipo você que ele vai de que que ele vai
falar
Ah entendi aqui que como ia ser porque
como eu já te acompanho um tempo a gente
se foram poucas vezes que a gente se viu
é ao vivo mas teve uma tem existe uma
conexão de energia cabeça é a conexão
que a gente alimenta quando a gente não
vai por esse outro lado entendeu tá
ligado Tipo assim
tem muitas pessoas que eu vou atrás
assim às vezes na internet que eu vejo
um comportamento estranho da pessoa um
pouco
três meses sem postar uma foto assim uma
pessoa que eu vi que era muito ativo era
muito feliz e tudo mais e tá assim eu
sempre que eu vejo eu vou atrás para
conversar das pessoas e geralmente essas
pessoas são as pessoas que são um pouco
rejeitadas assim sim obrigado é uma
galera que tipo já tentou ser aceito
naquela rodinha não deu naquela não deu
naquela não deu naquela não deu virou um
lobo solitário e não sabe ser só
entendeu porque o meu acho que o meu
maior Talvez o meu maior trunfo na vida
é saber ser só
Talvez seja isso o que fez eu chegar
onde eu cheguei sejam saber ser só Lobo
Solitário tá ligado Vou trabalhando aqui
galera tá aqui conversando tá
trabalhando comigo nossa tá ótimo tô
curtindo legal fico aqui nossa tranquilo
Começou assim a não andar comigo A não
tá na mesma sintonia na mesma ideia eu
já vou por ali encontro outra galera e
assim eu vou nômade sabe mas será que
tem a ver com signo porque você é
capricórnio que nem eu pode ser também
eu sempre me senti deslocada e a vontade
onde eu estou e já com aquela com a
cabeça desapegada porque eu sei que lá
na frente talvez eu não esteja aqui
então eu vivo que eu tenho que viver
cria um laço e se não tá se não bater a
mesma frequência dele para frente eu
vejo não vejo como um problema
simplesmente eu vejo como Ah não é para
ser assim
eu peço também tipo que é possível é
possível que aconteça qualquer coisa eu
tô conversando com a pessoa e aí tava aí
aí beleza é seu amigo da pessoa e Ok mas
aí a ideia não tá batendo mais eu sempre
penso assim não você perfeitamente
possível que não dá certo essa amizade
eu pensei o IPCA que você me chamou por
você já ter passado por uma situação de
aflição que a gente não consegue
expressar pelo lado artístico das coisas
a gente tem a cabeça muito frita
criativa e por você ter entendido o que
aconteceu então é o primeiro programa
que eu venho Desde de quando eu saí é
com o Lucas talvez foi a situação que eu
achei mais assim porque tipo acho que eu
tenho a parada da depressão tá ligado E
aí tipo essa parada de você ficar só e
ninguém lhe entender um pouco porque
você fala ninguém na casa vai lá
estranha entendeu Tipo tá ligado
não foi você que não foi isso que dá um
eu vi a cena eu falei meu Deus tudo bem
eu tava bem louca ali a fulana tava bem
louca mas não tinha ninguém 19 pessoas
na casa
isso que eu fiquei questionando se
alguém tivesse conversado não na porta
tá ligado porque ninguém tem que como eu
te falei que o meu compare a situação
acho que ninguém você não precisa
conversar com a pessoa quando ela tá na
beira do prédio entendeu
é conversar tá ligado é conversar normal
é tipo é aquele cara que vocês esbarra
na rua que o cara fala assim
você sabe a mulher que fica rua tal e aí
você fala assim espera aí eu tô atrasado
e sai andando sabe se você soubesse um
pouco da vida daquele rapaz você teria
dito assim Bom dia meu amigo perdão pelo
esbarrão foi mal a rua fica ali em tal
lugar
viu tamo junto é nós não precisava
não precisava foi foi Nada justifica
sabe atitude de todos os brothers loucas
foram todos por mais que a carga mais
pesada tenha caído na minhas costas e
tem pessoas que acham que a saída dele
no dia fui eu que aquele dia a gente
tava se falando tranquilo é óbvio que eu
tive atitudes bem deprimentes antes mas
não foi a motivação ali naquele momento
era uma outra situação que tinha
acontecido realmente
e eu eu reconheço que eu contribuí para
esse sentimento dele de desistência todo
mundo ali teve esse sentimento é natural
né ter esse sentimento mas eu poderia
ter agido de outra forma e aí é um
menino muito inteligente então lá dentro
ele tentava É como essa cabeça dele e
explodir de tanta informação tanta coisa
que ele tinha para falar de tanta coisa
e lá tava todo mundo focado no jogo ou
em si próprio seus egos e aí artista
artista é egocêntrico já começa aí por
isso eu não entendi esse julgamento olha
como ela é narcisista egocêntrica gente
eu sou artista não existe um artista que
suba num palco que é chamada de Diva e
não se sinta porque senão egocêntrica
problema nem vai fazer o que tem que
fazer como é que vai chegar cantando que
você falando sobre poder estar bem se
você chega com então a artista a diva né
que eu nunca me considerei uma diva mas
o público faz isso com a gente então
a diva ela ela é narcisista então eu
tenho traços narcisistas não sei se o
correto o jeito que eu tô falando quando
eu chego na cidade para fazer show eu
não gosto que ninguém me veja é porque
para não perder a graça na hora de você
entendeu Eu sou eu quero que a pessoa
vai entender então tipo assim eu tô na
van aí eu vou sair para o hotel Aí eu
saio da mãe e você
tá ligado Por que que o índice faz isso
é tão legal
eu tava toda assim capenga lá no meu
estúdio aí chegou dois amigos Ah não
cadê a Carol com K poderosa eu quero a
Carol com cara poderosa Cadê vai lá
minha língua gosta de chicote e eu assim
ó
falei ah eu não vou mais falar dessas
coisas eu comecei a escrever música para
o meu álbum novo eu falava Ah não eu não
vou falar isso aqui ai meu DJ porque não
falei acho que não sou isso ele Ah não
sério falei eu acho
que vai cantar você não tá sentindo se
você não tava se sentindo empoderada e
grandona de fora aí tu não conseguiu
botar assim eu mando eu quero eu consigo
porque naquele momento você não tava
mandando eu não consegui nem nada dentro
da sua cabeça me sentindo uma bola de
bolha de sabão sabe quando a bolha de
sabão ela fica flutuando o vento então
ficou uma coisa assim então quando eu
saí eu sei tão ai tô assim assim depois
você cai na realidade veste o a roupa da
humildade entende bebe o chá da
humildade fala espera
eu não preciso me armar tão desse jeito
Não há necessidade disso e é muito
julgamento para tudo no meu caso tá
assim não se eu sorri é fingimento Se Eu
Chorar é fingimento se eu ficar séria
fingimento se eu falar qualquer coisa
fingimento falo até da cor das roupas
que eu uso que eu sempre usei todos os
tons de cores
que saco poxa eu cheguei eu assisti o
coringa Quando eu sair
eu já tinha assistido antes mas eu podia
partir de novo pela terceira vez para
poder ver as atitudes gente eu vou
assistir o coringa aqui chamei meu filho
minha mãe foi vamos assistir o coringa
meu filho falou de novo eu falei não
vamos entender assim aí a minha mãe mas
por que que a minha mãe não tinha
assistido ainda falei para ela a gente
julga
é uma analogia meio boba mas tudo bem
mas a gente julga ele tá fazendo
atrocidades e não ver o que aconteceu
antes a pessoa que machuca ela foi
machucada todo mundo já sabe desse
processo o bullying quem quem faz
bullying já sofreu bullying e aí a falta
de amor de acolhimento empatia faz com
que essas atitudes elas vão se inflando
dentro das pessoas mais corretas que
existem no
mundo então eu assistindo aquilo eu
conseguia entender a parte humana da
vilã que eu eu transformei e o público
amplicou porque você sabia todos os
porque eu sabia porque mas o público não
então a gente só foi entender esse lado
do Coringa quando a gente viu esse filme
que fala sobre as feridas dele a gente
sente dó de um vilão quando vê ele sendo
massacrado antes de cometer as atitudes
dele só que ninguém viu as cenas que eu
vivi passei de humilhação para chegar a
nível de chegar no programa desse num
reality e
agir como se eu tivesse lidando com
essas pessoas que me maltrataram durante
essa esse essa trajetória na minha
carreira e essas pessoas elas continuam
me perseguir e depois desse ódio
coletivo e desse cancelamento ela se
sentiram mais fortes então elas
continuam tripudiando e brincando com
essa situação de vilania real do lado
deles então Eles continuam na ameaça
continuam na humilhação continuam
tentando tirar todas as possibilidades
que eu tenho de seguir minha carreira
porque na cabeça deles eu preciso ser
cancelada de vez e aí teve um amigo meu
que ele falou assim Carol eu falei nossa
você tá aqui eu achei que você não ia
mais falar comigo você não ia ser meu
amigo todos os meus amigos continuaram
né tá todo mundo aqui tudo ele falou
Carol quem não tá agora nunca esteve
eu fiquei refletindo sobre isso falei
nunca esteve ele falou e outra se cada
atitude que você teve ali todo mundo que
tá jogando não tiver feito 10% do que
você fez aí são todos Alecrins Dourados
Como estão falando né não usou a palavra
empatia mas ele praticou a palavra
empatia tá ligado ele praticou porque
ele se colocou no seu lugar e disse se
cada um de nós não tiver feito igual que
que Jesus disse quando a galera tava com
uma pedra conte para mim atire a
primeira pedra quem nunca pecou atire a
primeira pedra aquele que nunca tomba
aquele que nunca tomba Quando eu via eu
falava assim Gente é muita gente se
unindo para não gostar de uma pessoa tá
ligado Tipo assim muita gente tem gente
tem gente que é bom a gente se unir para
não gostar mais
não é bom fazer isso tá ligado não
gostar de tipo querer que a pessoa morra
e
ficar desejando isso vendo que também um
monte de gente está desejando tá ligado
eu percebi até uma coisa em mim que eu
não percebia que era aquele negócio que
eu falei tipo tem um teto parece que
para mim tem um teto para maldade né
tipo
ali tá bom eu quero que ela saia aí
quando ela sair ela vai perder uns
contratos entendeu ela não tinha que tem
que ter
duas marca boa top grande entendeu mas
depois tá bom depois tá bom entendeu só
que aí que a gente vê que não tem limite
para isso as pessoas passam do limite se
você contribui um pouquinho para isso
você ajuda por isso que eu tipo tirei
meu time de campo
100%, porque eu não quero ganhar um
seguidor em cima disso eu não tô afim
desse perfil que que usou meu nome para
ganhar seguidor para é assim que eu saí
que tinha alguma coisa a ver com você
que tinha um milhão e tanto seguidores
mas assim sabe o que que eu penso
mesmo sendo algo negativo uma
repercussão negativa eu ajudei essas
pessoas de alguma forma mas eu te contar
uma parada assim que talvez te esclareça
esclareça não eu nem vou falar essa
palavra porque não pode mais falar né
mas é não das palavras que a gente tá
fazendo assim como que fala então que te
qual a palavra
seria o seguinte é a percepção que a
galera tem sobre a gente
atinge muita gente entendeu então essa
parada de te ver foram muitas pessoas
só que se você parar para prestar
atenção não importa se foram muitas
pessoas entendeu importa se fosse uma
importaria entendeu a gente pensa que a
gente tem a obrigação de explicar para
todo mundo o que aconteceu só que a
gente não tem ser uma pessoa pública
parece que diz para a gente
automaticamente tipo assim não não você
não pode deixar que fica assim você tem
que fazer isso você tem que fazer aquilo
só que você tem que fazer o melhor para
você você não tem que fazer o melhor
para o seu empresário
[Música]
você não tem que fazer o melhor para
ninguém sabe porque cada um tem sua
caminhada a pessoa que trabalhou com
vocês se ela deixar trabalhar com você
hoje a caminhada dela amanhã é procurar
alguém para trabalhar não é a Carol
tirou não não é isso não a Carol é uma
pessoa que passou pela vida dela como
qualquer uma não é porque você é artista
né porque você é famosa Ah mas olha o
que eu passei por situações do tipo tá
trabalhando no lugar com pessoas me
senti sufocada e desrespeitada pedir
para sair e a pessoa sair falando que
acabou a vida dela porque eu respeitei
meu livre arbítrio de querer sair de
querer de não estar no mesmo ambiente e
a pessoa isso tem muitos anos e a pessoa
até hoje carrega essa amargura de ela me
abandonou grata por causa dela por ela
não estar aqui a minha vida acabou e
assim que poder é esse que eu tenho de
anular a vida de qualquer outra pessoa
se eu tô tão ocupada com a minha vida
para construir a minha
sabe
exato se eu tenho todo esse poder a
vacina já estaria aqui com todo mundo
então eu fico pensando eu falo assim eu
se eu não culpo as outras pessoas pelas
minhas falhas e derrotas eu não vou
deixar que me façam responsável pelas
derrotas alheias porque eu sei
exatamente o que eu faço e o que eu falo
e eu percebo que não foi nada além de
erros momentâneos comigo que só fez mal
para mim não mal para essas pessoas
eu nunca roubei eu nunca deixei de pagar
e tiveram muitas gente teve muita fake
News teve apareceu o grupo de bailarina
dizendo que eu não paguei eles eu com
documento comprovando que eles foram
pagos é muito triste
e ela saiu comeu um açaí aqui e não
pagou não viu sério aí eu falo assim tá
é mais fácil falar ela tá sendo uma vaca
lá dentro um lixo do que ficar
inventando que não me vamos aproveitar
agora que ela tá queimada vai ser a
palavra dela contra a nossa e com
certeza não acredita na gente porque ela
já vilã Não porque eu tenho provas
documentos que comprovam que eu fiz as
coisas certinho então é muito ruim eu já
tinha mais confiança uma dificuldade de
confiar nas pessoas e agora fica pior
sabe eu preciso passar dessa etapa de eu
preciso confiar nas pessoas
eu confio em quem que eu confio porque a
realidade da pessoa é que a pessoa me
mostra isso tipo
se ela tiver me mostrando uma coisa que
ela não é então eu tô vendido aqui
porque eu tô
adorando
ser amigo dessa pessoa que [ __ ] é tudo
isso que ela tá falando tá ligado Olha
tá ligado esse cara tá dizendo que fez
investimento isso e fez aquilo e para
papai e tem um negócio louco para
conversar comigo ali e tudo mais e tal
então tu pode ser uma pessoa que tem
realmente um investimento massa uma
parada Legal ou pode ser a realidade que
o cara também mostrando que não é a
verdadeira entendeu e eu posso estar
viajando na maionese Não é uma coisa que
não não tá acontecendo e a gente aí
[ __ ] sempre que eu converso com alguém
eu conto toda minha vida toda eu conto
meus projetos todo e bota música para
ouvir
e quero fazer isso quero fazer aquilo aí
eu vou fazer isso vou fazer isso e isso
e aquilo e isso e aquilo e vou contando
tudo e a pessoa E aí vai me mostrando só
o que ela quer me só o que ela quer o
que ela acha que é legal dela aí depois
eu não sei que a pessoa não paga não sei
quem ou que a pessoa não
tem treta com um amigo meu não sei aonde
porque pegou não sei quê não fica
sabendo depois só depois que você já
contou tudo porque eu sou assim eu tô
conversando com a pessoa eu [ __ ] quando
tudo mano já era então essa coisa de
ideia eu aprendi a né mas assim muito de
falar mas sabe o que que é é tipo assim
é mais você vê a vida não Big Brother
Mas você vê a vida como um game
realmente e realmente tem jogadores que
estão mais à frente tá ligado eles são
esperto Eles são muito Nossa eles eles
são muito bons tá ligado eles são bons
em convencer e conversar e manipular tá
ligado E aí o que que tem que acontecer
o que tem que acontecer é que você tem
que ter um primeiro despertar que é
assim qual é o meu game é bom ou é ruim
é bom né então tá então tudo que vem
daqui para cá eu sempre tenho um pé
atrás eu não digo nunca não para tudo
que eu que eu não concordo porque a
malícia às vezes é bom um pouquinho para
você
entender algumas peças do game tá ligado
e é bom você entender e tudo mais mas
tipo assim você tem que estar muito
Alerta com as pessoas porque é como se
fosse realmente o Big Brother o que
acontece comigo por exemplo eu aprendi
como você falou agora você aprendeu a
questão das ideias depois que eu aprendi
eu tô conversando com você aqui Chegou
outra pessoa eu paro
[Música]
Nossa tá grande
é que como dá para ver
[Música]
depressão
você não entende muito então vou falar
uma parada você não vai entender eu já
não entendo então vou ficar mais confuso
Então é melhor não falar tá ligado Então
eu não falo tá ligado aí amanhã eu falo
assim quer saber eu vou tomar um banho
eu vou fazer minha barba e eu vou
em dias normais vai falar assim eu vou
no cinema entendeu E aí você vai no
cinema e fala assim ah tá com depressão
e vai no cinema Faz Gente eu tô tentando
sair do ponto a ao ponto b entendeu E
vocês estão no e-mail
me impedindo vocês também tentando me me
dizer que eu devo ficar de uma forma e
eu não devo não é sempre essa é igual
quando eu falei tô com uma tristeza
profunda não consigo me sentir feliz aí
me falaram ah para né você deu picos de
audiência você estava maravilhosa
eu não acho interessante eu não gosto tô
triste ah mas você é conhecida Ah mas
você tem talento você pode fazer música
e sair por cima entendeu para ele você
não é uma pessoa normal você é alguém
Imaculada realmente diferente quando
você entra dentro do carro ele se
transforma e aparece no Rio de Janeiro
não é assim que acontece a parada eu
fico triste aí falar mas já foi ao pior
já passou e você tava lá dentro você nem
viu eu falo não pior para quem assiste
agora o pior para quem é aquilo e viveu
Aquilo é outra história então a minha
batalha é não cair numa depressão por
isso eu faço acompanhamento para não
cair numa depressão que tem várias
coisas que pegam Né desde o trauma de se
expor ao se reconhecer
[Música]
e não ter tanto controle
eu ainda me sinto
me sinto vendida me sinto
[Música]
uma coisa como se eu fosse um negócio
que as pessoas jogam para lá e para cá e
tiram suas próprias conclusões E aquele
negócio é outra coisa e ter que lidar
com isso com a rejeição dessas pessoas e
ainda com a insistência de inimigos que
não se contentam que dizer para si mesmo
tipo todo dia vai dar certo vai dar
certo isso também vai passar vai passar
isso também vai passar
e assim muitos falam não mas você
deveria voltar tá muito sumida das redes
chega e mostra que você tá arrasando que
você tá poderosa mostra qual aonde você
tá eu falo para quê Porque que eu vou
fazer isso ai para a gente saber o que
que você tá fazendo mas para que
entendeu porque
não tô bem Ah mas duvido que ela tá mal
não eu não estou bem não tô legal
entendeu então assim é óbvio que eu
consigo dar risada durante o dia de
algumas coisas mas são frames se fossem
outra situação essa entrevista a gente
já tá rindo muito mais porque o meu
natural essa é uma coisa mais cômica e
as pessoas acham que a força ou rimas
fortes não estão ligados a bom humor ou
que o deboche ele não pode estar ligado
o sarcasmo que tá ligado a uma mente
criativa o brasileiro é debochado a
gente é sarcástico o tempo inteiro aí
debocham do meu deboche e eu não posso
debochar do meu próprio deboche e
devolver o deboche do deboche que tá
debochando
Já que é para filosofar filosofia
quer tombar não tem como tombar mais o
que eu já tô bem gente ó falaram para
mim do chão não passa mas acho que eu
passei eu fui até o inferno
deixar
o céu no pole dance até o inferno
foi isso que aconteceu comigo eu tava lá
no céu de repente ó de preferida eu fui
[Música]
Só faltou sentar no colo da gaveta legal
você viu esse clipe do Leonardo meu Deus
ele literalmente Senta no Colo do capeta
também para fazer uma uma parada uma
parada que é bem chocante e você vai ter
que lidar com tudo aquilo que vem depois
e tal
tem que estar muito bem às vezes eu
penso em fazer uns trabalhos assim
também não lógico uma coisa chocante
assim
mas eu fiquei com vontade de fazer uma
coisa chocante eu sendo a apedrejada
artista ele quer expressar expressão é
isso sabe aquele passinho do Recife que
a galera
é uma expressão de favela pô a galera
reúne a galera tenta falar a galera
tenta brigar com o governo galera Tenta
pedir uma melhor ali e aí a ela se une
culturalmente e expressa alguma coisa e
sai de alguma forma
toma toma
porque é uma mensagem de favela foi uma
mensagem que a favela toma toma toma tá
ligado a mensagem é essa ela diz isso
ela é expressada daquele momento por que
que ele
acontece não adianta você quer expressar
de algum jeito ou é não uma música ou é
Num tanto que quando por exemplo uma
pessoa que é um civil normal ele nenhum
cantor e nenhum compositor mas às vezes
no aniversário de namoro ele fala assim
eu vou fazer uma música para ela aí ele
escreve aquela musiquinha bem simplinha
conversas bem simplinho mas é ele
tentando expressar um pouquinho
espremendo o coração dele e saindo um
pouquinho de arte Ah tá ligado Então dou
maior valor essa parada de você se
expressar de alguma forma é uma música é
um estilo então a gente canta muitas
vezes sobre aquilo que a gente quer ou a
gente é ou a gente teve e no meu caso O
Poder Em alguns momentos eu me sentir
poderosa em outros não e também em
alguns casos se a gente não se sente que
quer de nós
se a gente não tem o ditado se você não
se sente
[ __ ] quem que vai te achar fora então
assim a gente vive numa sociedade que
fala que não pode julgar mas julga que
fala para ter mais autoestima mais
reprime a pessoa mas chama de
egocêntrico psicopata uma pessoa que se
sente bem ou chama de como que é
ixi é um branco aqui eu entendi tipo a
pessoa a pessoa se impõe no seu lugar
onde pode se impor um pouco e aí você
não pode né
eu tinha que ser submissa porque eu
tenho esse problema na minha cabeça não
quero ser uma mulher submissa Ah porque
que a Carol fala tanto disso pô mas
porque eu cresci Numa família onde
mulheres não eram submissas mulheres
eram fortes minha avó era espancada todo
dia para o meu vô e ele só parou quando
ela reagiu
e quando ela reagiu ele saiu de casa
então eu aprendi que quando você reage
você vai ser vista como vila sempre além
de espantar o problema para você né que
a sua leitura sua visão é que você está
espantando o problema sim independente
das atitudes que eu tive na casa se eu
não tivesse tido aquelas aquele tão
agressivo ainda assim talvez eu estaria
cancelada ou por não ter me posicionado
ou por ter me posicionado na hora errada
ou por ter a verdade é que nunca nada e
talvez fosse Pior né porque tipo de
agora quando tipo a galera tipo [ __ ]
quis te reduzir ao zero aí tu tem de
onde ressurgir né E se tu tivesse ido só
cancelada pela metade tivesse tipo numa
situação chata agora né
sem sentar-se
reentendendo isso imagina tu só tivesse
tipo lidando com aquele e falando Ah a
galera errou em mim
eu ia continuar montado na soberba que é
onde eu tava quando eu tava no reality
que é
pelo amor de deus
eu me perdoa que eu tenho vontade
de nada e a gente quer acostumada a ter
tudo do nosso jeito na nossa vida então
escuta a música que eu quiser a hora que
eu quiser eu vou trabalhar o horário que
eu quiser às vezes não mas eu gosto
também eu gosto muito de trabalhar aí
chega num ambiente não é do jeito que
você quer eu fui mó mimada às vezes eu
às vezes eu eu paro também para mim
olhar para mim um pouco e falar assim eu
tenho que cuidar um pouco para não virar
uma pessoa porque acontece isso comigo
também tipo a gente a gente quer beber
um negócio e esse negócio aparece
tá ligado a gente tem artista E tem tipo
já já tem uma uma produção e tem uma
galera que trabalha e quer trabalhar
Sabe eles querem fazer as coisas tudo
rápido pra gente né eles que agradar bem
direitinho para não faltar nada então
tipo assim a gente fala que quer comer o
negócio pensa que não o negócio tá ali
aí a gente fala quer fazer uma parada só
que não já tá feita aqui esse negocinho
aqui eu falei que queria um podcast esse
aqui já tava feito tá ligado isso E aí a
gente acostumado com isso e a gente tem
que cuidar um pouquinho para não
acostumar tanto com isso que não perder
a realidade assim Sabe às vezes eu eu
fico falando com os meninos também tipo
eu converso com os meninos e fico
esperando que eles me corrijam um pouco
faz isso também às vezes
Credo eu faço muitas vezes isso vou
postar uma foto minha de cueca no meu
Twitter é só para ver alguém falar Não
não faz isso
eu quero saber se a minha galera tá
online comigo você é a galera
tá vai lá porque eu gosto de me cercar
de pessoas que falam não é o tal do Fala
na cara porque essa frase fala na cara é
muito agressiva tá vendo
eu não sou uma pessoa assim que fala na
cara Eu meço minhas palavras mas eu
gosto de pessoas que sejam reais então
eu estou viajando e eu sou pirada eu
falo pirada no meu sentido agora Fico
até sem falar que eu sou pirata Mas eu
sou eu tenho uma mente criativa então eu
começo assim nossa eu vou viajar para
tal lugar fazer isso isso se a pessoa
fala ai vai ser incrível aí eu falo para
uma outra coisa eu vou até o 13 na
terceira nessas três alguém falar não
sei o quê aí eu já olha aquelas outras
vezes Já chamam para conversa eu falo
assim ia me deixar fazer isso isso
e você sabe que ela sabe da sua agenda
você sabe que ela sabe da sua o que você
tem que fazer mas ela tava te apoiando a
fazer uma parada como você fazer porque
a sua agenda tá lotada então tipo é bom
você ficar esperto ali naquele momento
né Sempre tem aquela pessoa que que pó
da gente que eu amo que precisamos disso
que fala ó não é bem por aí e tem
aquelas pessoas que apanham Nossa
loucura e as pessoas que falam Olha onde
tiver indo estamos aí eu quero ver você
bem então tem que é no momento que eu
saí da casa dos dois meses assim posso
sair daí eu ficava já faz dois meses
dois meses eu ficava assim meu Deus eu
não confio mais da minha intuição no meu
achismo mas por que Carol você tem que
confiar em você eu falo como eu me botei
eu me botei não um mês eu confiei lá
dentro também não acertei nas
gente eu não acertei vamos ver o que que
eu acertei falando assim ó francamente
Deus Olha eu acho muito bom a gente vai
para trás e ver as cagadas porque eu
também sou desse jeito também mano o que
acontece eu tava falando tipo eu só não
sou filmado
mas eu totalmente
quatro horas por dia tentando encontrar
uns erros umas coisas que eu falei um
negócio que eu não quis dizer um negócio
que eu não quis pensar porque às vezes
tem o pensamento também eu falava tudo
que eu pensava é entendeu a gente
máquina sai pela boca máquina sai pela
boca
era muito ainda bem que você não
assistiu deve ser por isso Brasil que
ele me recebe aqui porque ele não viu o
que vocês viram Eu também
Nossa então já viu o suficiente
nossa eu falei muita besteira e ali para
quem me conhece mesmo fala nossa tá com
ataque de ansiedade Sinistro e as
pessoas não sabem o que é ansiedade né
tanto que meu DJ que trabalha comigo ele
falou mas o que a ansiedade mesmo em si
Ela tem ela tem várias características
eu explico a todo mundo tipo assim antes
de depressão gente a depressão não é só
ficar triste a depressão ela faz você
perder as pessoas que você ama tá ligado
porque a pessoa vem falar uma parada com
você
e ela não entende e você não entende
também tá ligado então tipo vai tomar no
cu então então Vai para [ __ ] que pariu
tá entendendo é assim também tá ligado
Tipo assim não é só igual a palavra
empatia ah empatia eu me boto no lugar
não é muito mal demais
não é só se colocar no lugar do outro é
você é você eliminar o seu ego vai dar
de orgulho aquilo que bota você lá em
cima você parar e botar você e se ver em
cada situação da perda da vida da pessoa
e você se troca não só da vida da pessoa
como da pessoa que cerca a pessoa como
namorado da pessoa como do amigo da
pessoa como da prima da prima da pessoa
você não quer que a pessoa lá na porta
em Roraima fique triste eu não quero
entendeu então tipo assim é isso tá
ligado Então da mesma forma
eu ficava tipo
você afasta as pessoas que você gosta de
você entendeu você você faz as pessoas
que Sabotagem é afastar mesmo que quando
tem aquelas crianças
que a gente fala assim para não faz isso
e a criança é tão atentada que ela olha
para tua cara e faz de novo
eu me senti assim é quase como se ela
tivesse tentando mandar uma mensagem né
isso e geralmente quando quando é caso
de criança que é muito atentada assim é
que tem alguma coisa que não tá bem eu
falo isso porque eu era uma criança
muito especificada depois Teve uma época
que eu fiquei impossível na sala de aula
e uma professora falou assim olha ela
faz isso porque ela não tem atenção em
casa ela quer chamar atenção e aquilo
ficou na minha cabeça eu cheguei em casa
e falei mãe vocês não me dão atenção
porque a professora falou que eu quero
chamar atenção ela falou Olha você desde
pequena é muito
estralada daí ela brincava que é porque
eu tinha nascido O Primeiro de Janeiro e
aí eu ouvi os barulhos dos fogos e
fiquei e eu acreditava nisso né
tipo fala que alguma coisa que a gente
tem é porque aconteceu um momento
Obrigado Nossa é isso né E aí eu comecei
a perceber Qual era a situação que eu
tinha na minha casa meu pai alcoólatra
meu irmão teve leucemia com 5 aninhos
minha mãe precisou ficar com foco Total
nele no hospital e eu me sentia
rejeitada Mas isso era uma coisa que eu
sentia não que eles faziam comigo mas eu
me sentia assim cadê a minha mãe cadê o
meu pai eu não entendi porque que quando
eu fazia músicas de amor e poema para o
meu pai ele não tava ali para ouvir ele
preferia ficar no bar aqui em casa eu só
fui entender que ele tinha uma doença
doença do alcoolismo com 14 15 anos
quando ele faleceu e aí eu comecei a
chamar atenção no colégio
então tem ele era doente né tinha o
alcoolismo só que ele morreu de uma
maneira muito estúpida ele
regurgitou a bebida respirou e foi para
o pulmão e aí ele morreu mas se não
fosse isso mais um pouquinho para frente
ele teria falecido com a filha de uma
amiga minha que ela
espirrou e o catarro entrou pelo lugar
é uma morte estúpida né porque você fala
como assim não é para acontecer é e eu
fiquei muito tempo mal porque eu não
consegui me despedir do meu pai eu havia
discutido com ele uma semana antes da
morte dele porque ele era bêbado e minha
mãe já tinha separado dele e ele tava
morando com a minha avó eu falei se eu
for até aí te visitar e você tiver
bêbado Eu nunca mais vou e aí eu fui ele
tava bêbado eu não entendia que ele não
tinha controle eu não fui visitar ele e
ele começou a me ligar fazendo
contagem regressiva da morte dele isso
eu nunca contei eu contei no Doc e agora
assim porque eu já tô resolvendo essas
questões com psicólogo terapeuta mas eu
não conseguia falar sobre isso tem que
conversar com a galera para ajeitar a
tua cabeça Você já mandou tudo
e ele falava faltam tantos dias faltam
três dias faltam dois dias aí ele falou
Amanhã você não vai me ver e eu nunca
mais vi ele e eu falei ele chamou a
morte porque ele falava que queria
morrer entendeu antes de todo dele ir
morar com a minha avó ele comentava que
a vida não tinha graça meu pai tinha
depressão e eu só fui entender mais para
frente mais velha e ele falava eu não
quero viver
e parece a morte foi tão estúpida que eu
pensei Ele chamou a morte
depois eu vi minha tia
falando eu não vejo mais graça ela teve
meloma
indo E aí quando eu me vi na estação de
quero morrer eu lembrava do meu pai que
quando ele falava não tenho mais vontade
de viver lembrei da minha tia quando ela
falou a mesma coisa que perdeu a graça
do mundo e eu me senti igual assim nossa
não vejo graça no mundo e a minha equipe
minha família amigos começaram não você
fez coisa errada fez mas olha quanta
coisa boa você Já construiu aí eu tive
que fazer esse processo você mesmo
construir esse caminho né É porque pode
estar milhões de pessoas ao seu redor
falando vai levanta levanta se você não
levanta nada vai te levantar e pode ter
milhares de pessoas falando deita deita
e você falar eu vou levantar
a sua levantadas
Nossa essa coisa de você
não sentir à vontade de estar aqui né eu
falo assim que quando
que a gente podia não tá né aqui mas a
gente tá
a gente podia não estar a gente podia
não estar aqui mas a gente tá e se a
gente tá
porque não fazer dessa passagem né uma
coisa muito
incrível para nós mesmo entendeu porque
tipo assim o que tu deve tá sentindo
agora é uma parada de tipo reconquistar
uma galera só que tipo a parada tem que
ser legal para nós mesmo
não se gostar muito você falou muito
alto o amor né sobre Auto sobre isso
Auto Sabotagem tá ligado Então tem uma
parada muito da gente se achar
incrível e eu descobri que a minha
soberba eu comecei a prestar atenção
nessa lance da soberba foi uma pera aí
tá a gente acha que a soberba tá ligado
só se tivesse acontecido comigo o que
aconteceu com você eu acho que eu teria
esquecido aquela pessoa ali de dentro já
não teria não estaria mais contando com
aquilo ali aquilo ali não seria mais
Base além de tudo já foi isso tudo
não faz mais sentido para mim não faz
nem um pouco de sentido não não eu não
me vejo ali eu acho que eu fico
diferente depois ficou mais Branda tu
ficou diferente depois ficou mais Branda
não na verdade eu sempre fui mais assim
é desse mais tranquila
a única diferença é que eu fui mais
alegre e mais espontânea mais cômica
agora
é na minha vida natural são mais Come
que mais alegre do que isso no momento
ainda estou sabe assim
tô tem umas forças um pouco de
porcentagem que eu fico irritada comigo
com aquela Carol
sensacionais na vida tipo e
você não é diferente dessas pessoas eu
me eu me para me confortar de muitas
coisas que eu penso eu penso isso eu
penso que tipo assim nossa tem gente que
se recompõe de uma situação que eu falo
assim meu amigo eu não ia conseguir isso
sério não ia acontecer comigo Entendeu
já no teu caso eu vejo que
[Música]
é uma coisa que dá para
tá ligado que é uma coisa que
é que não estava falando não é um crime
não é um Não não é nada
acho que assim já chegaram e falar isso
você é tão criativa com as coisas que
até na hora da Vila ania da sua amargura
do seu estresse tinha criatividade é
isso que fascinou esse o público a
querer a pedrejar mais mas ainda assim
eles preferem ficar falando de mim então
qualquer coisa que aconteça eles lembram
daquela Carol tanto que transformaram
queria saber quem foi a pessoa que fez o
meme do paredão Como assim foi do nada
aconteceu foi depois foi muito depois
gente eu tava quieta no meu canto aí no
meu celular começa apitar Assessoria
assim Carol você tá vendo o que tá
acontecendo nas redes eu falei não não
tô acessando veja
e a boquinha
que não gostou e sabe essa boquinha eu
vou explicar aqui para você da onde é
que só meu amigo se ligou é que a gente
quando a gente tá junto a gente fala que
a gente fica tão Frito de fazer música
que a gente começa a falar assim e a
gente é do Paraná então a gente tira
sarro da gente mesmo nosso tac e ele é
do interior então ele sempre a gente
começa a carregar nosso sotaque Eu tô
muito contente com esse presente e aí
tem esse
dente da gente praticamente demente é
tudo assim sabe E aí e a gente faz essa
boquinha do vou te bater o guria e eu
fiz essa boca qualquer coisa entendeu E
aí eu pego e eu
ai gente agora já consigo rir dessa
situação mas a boquinha e a cara fechada
Também quebrou o braço em 1999 hoje fala
e fala sorrindo
Mas tipo assim
a gente consegue brincar e é o que eu
digo aos meus amigos tô muito triste eu
digo para você amigo daqui a uns quatro
anos Isso é só uma lembrança engraçada
para você nossa é uma lembrança
engraçada você vai rir você vai de secar
essa situação a torto e a direita a
pessoa vai falar assim e você não ficou
mal por isso você fala sim fiquei passou
meu Deus a boquinha torta ainda tem o
ponto lá que eu só fui ver depois que eu
sei que tem o tal do ponto ainda é que
eu continuo no violão qualquer coisa me
bota no paredão entendeu
daí faz a boquinha que eu faço com a
base em drama que eu tenho minha
carreira bem bonita lá fora daí eu pego
e falo e pronto não é nem pronto e esse
ponto eu e o drama falando assim e aí
ele falava assim amiga
parecia que você tava eu e você no
estúdio você tirando onda ele falou aqui
fora o povo achando que você era toda
aquela pessoa amarga é igual quando eu
vi ele falou Desculpe desculpe gente e a
boquinha
e o povo assim ai a boca de noia
ai gente eu tenho
como que eu vou aqui nossa olha a
boquinha de [ __ ] dela aí eu ficava
voltando o vídeo acho que milhares de
pessoas eram votaram só a parte que eu
fico e ponto e ponto ó aí tem
a baba do veneno
tem um vídeo no YouTube com uma hora de
me bota no paredão Você acredita gente
gente juro para você eu Olha quando eu
vi eu falei quem
quem meu Deus faz isso eu seria essa
pessoa o cara parou será que eu sou essa
pessoa
me bota sem parar uma hora eu falei não
é possível de 15 minutos porque a galera
para né
E essa fala eu falei mas essa fala é da
onde que aconteceu nesse jogo Eu não
lembrar foi logo após a cena deprimente
da mesa
um combo de coisa que você nem lembrava
não lembrava todas não gostaram daquela
cena mas fizeram um meme daquela cena
que tanto machuca todo mundo e me
machuca também e aí você consegue
entender o Brasil eu sou igual ao Brasil
Brasil igual a mim no sentido de eu
achei que era só eu que tirava sarda
própria desgraça para aliviar a dor mas
acho que a dor foi tão grande para o
brasileiro que eles tiraram sarro desse
momento para dar uma aliviada na
decepção sei lá não tava bem não também
não não tava numa pandemia naquele
momento ali a galera tava tava bem tensa
tava bem estranha também e para as
pessoas esquecerem o número de mortes
por covid no nosso país para minha
apedrejar aí você vê que a população não
tá muito bem da cabeça priorizar o
linchamento de uma artista em
desequilíbrio emocional não reality
ao invés de priorizar cuidados com covid
eu não sei o que pensar eu levo a sério
esse hate é um rate de um povo que erra
mais do que eu
mas eu também não tiro a
culpa da Galera porque culpa para falar
a verdade quem tem né sem medo dessa
dessa
[ __ ] loucura
razão Não dou porque não tem razão para
dar para isso também tá ligado Tipo é
que nem eu tava te falando tipo eu curti
os primeiros momentos de tortura tá
ligado
tá se achando eu vou acabar com ela
eu sei porque eu sou igual eu comecei a
ver que tava desmedido eu comecei a ver
que tava muita gente aí eu comecei a ver
que era todo mundo aí eu comecei a ver
que a galera Estava combinando de tirar
na maior de todos os tempos aí eu falei
espera aí galera que vocês estão
planejando né a modinha da dança do Tik
Tok então todo mundo faz tantan todo
mundo fazendo a mesma coisa para ganhar
regiões de likes seguidores hoje a
dancinha é odiar a Carol com K mas
ninguém quis levantar um tema sério
sobre o que estava acontecendo na casa
nem eu nem outros participantes merecem
ser julgados porque tem pessoas que
ficam julgando atitude do Lucas a
atitude da Carol a atitude não sei quem
Ninguém merece ser julgado ninguém velho
sabe então eu vejo as pessoas mais esse
povo aí não são Santo ai passar pano o
que precisamos falar sobre o que é o
cancelamento e o que é a passada de pano
passar pano é você ser cúmplice do erro
de alguém e falar isso aí fingir que não
vi agora você acolher a falar apontar o
erro e mostrar a direção certa Isso faz
parte da evolução
o cancelamento ele faz parte de um outro
de um sentido bem contrário ao que é
Divino
um tempo um tempo eu tive medo depois eu
já queria que me cancelasse logo que
você pensa assim se me cancelar logo
amor que para de encher meu saco
entendeu
E aí depois eu passei a pensar que
realmente não faz diferença a galera não
tudo bem tem aquele baque Inicial que se
dá o artista pensa e tudo mais lá e
ainda nem um artista às vezes é só uma
figura pública mesmo às vezes é só uma
pessoa que falou uma merda uma palavra e
aí a galera faz o tal do cancelamento
mas que o cancelamento vira mais uma
palavra do que nem empatia do que
empatia cancelamento entendeu
a galera Tenta dar uma cancelada e a
pessoa vai lá entende seu erro e aí
volta e acaba que o cancelamento
realmente ele não espécie de fato
cancelar cortar não dá até porque
ninguém tira tua criatividade ninguém
tira a tua a tua forma de se Reinventar
uma pessoa melhor então é muito ruim
quando a gente
transfere nossas angústias em outra
pessoa é ruim fazer isso eu falo por
experiência própria eu peguei minha
angústia tentei transferir
numa briga com outras pessoas e não me
trouxe nada de bom então não vai trazer
nada de bom para essas pessoas
transferirem angústia delas em cima de
mim que tô tentando me tornar uma pessoa
melhor tô fazendo exatamente aqueles me
pediram para fazer mas tratava você é
uma pessoa melhor aí eu tô nesse
processo Eles continuam tá fingindo não
é certo ah lá agora tá atuando é morre
Tá apareceu chorando antes não chorou na
saída do riacho tá chorando agora porque
porque nós artistas somos condicionados
a ligar
também eu já hemorragia eu já fiz show
passando mal
tendo Mega sangramento
e sorrindo você ficou né
Entendeu aí nesse dia ele resolveu que
ele saiu do lugar saiu assim no lugar e
eu levantei meu ombro fora do lugar e a
galera sorrindo essa piada engraçada foi
ali na coxinha eu falei puxa aqui Puxa
aqui eu quero meu braço fica assim
aí eu voltei e fiz o
e o que tá fazendo show pulando pulando
no Saltitante eu usava aquelas unhas
gigantes de gel e é o pulando igual um
cabritinho assim o meu o meu calcanhar
enquanto conforme eu corria pulava bateu
na minha mão que veio para trás assim
bateu arrancou a unha inteira com sangue
tudo eu continuei o show bem Maravilhosa
a unha voou na cara de alguém essa
pessoa segurou a unha e ficou aqui
mostrando para minha unha e eu assim
cantando e o negócio começou a sangrar e
eu aqui
maravilhosa acabou o show chamar um
bombeiro
jogaram álcool ardeu muito eu chorava eu
falava Gente o que que tá acontecendo e
a unha ali e aí meu dia falou mas eu não
vi na hora do show não vi as pessoas não
vem porque a gente já tá condicionado a
gente se treina para isso show é show
espetáculo espetáculo então quando eu
saí do reality eu tava no modo Palco
Show
espetáculo sei lá o que eu não mude
preciso estar bem apresentável mesmo na
derrota mas o porquê isso Ela é
psicopata ela não tem sentimento não
porque eu sou uma artista
porque eu não posso eu aprendi na minha
família aqui mulher preta não pode ser
vulnerável não pode não pode demonstrar
fraqueza porque o que faz um racista
sentir prazer é ver a gente chorar então
por isso eu não chorei porque eu sabia
que dentro e aqueles todos votos e Ódio
coletivo tinha também o ódio
do racismo e falando agora a gente vai
ver ela cair e eu não quis dar isso
é foi por orgulho por ser uma
gente eu sou uma artista que faz rap
muitos não me consideram rapper mas o
rap ele não tá ligado só a letra e a
melodia que você queria tá ligado ao
estilo de vida e ser rap não no meu caso
não tá ligado a estar com arma ou notas
de dinheiro chacoalhando na frente da
câmera é o estilo Rap de si é ser uma
mulher no rap então não é só cantar um
sol em cima da batida e fazer gestos
agressivos tem um lance aqui que você
tem que saber jogar entendeu e eu tive
que passar por muitas situações para
chegar na posição que eu tô e entender
que eu não cheguei até aqui para ser uma
fraca eu represento milhares de pessoas
mulheres que se identificam e se
identificavam comigo e vão vir se
identificar Então acho que a fraqueza
ela nunca pode estar ligada a mulher
preta principalmente na minha cabeça é
assim que funciona
e vai demorar muito tempo para isso sair
da minha cabeça Talvez isso nunca saia
eu tenho que me manter forte
eu entendo também tipo é como quando eu
penso Lógico que nada se compara né mas
às vezes eu penso quando as pessoas
falam assim nossa como você tem tanta
ideia como você faz tanta coisa eu falo
assim cara é porque quem nasceu onde eu
nasci tem que fazer 10 coisas para poder
para poder tá igual a vocês aqui tá
ligado eu não tenho como só ser
engraçado eu tenho que ser engraçado eu
tenho que ser o melhor tem que ser
Boxeador eu tenho que ser compositor eu
tenho que ser isso e aquilo e aquilo e
aquilo e aquilo porque senão você
ninguém porque tem um cara que nasceu
aqui mais por perto que só por ele
cantar bem e ele já tá na minha frente
mano tá ligado Tipo eu morei lá na [ __ ]
assim na [ __ ] que pariu eu lá sei onde
ninguém quer saber tá ligado ninguém
quer saber as capitais porque a galera
pensa que o sotaque é o mesmo de todo
lugar é o medo você tá aqui nordestino
do piauítas Estado do Piauí eu sou do
Aracaju
eu sou da da de Natal Rio Grande do
Norte Então você tá aqui em Natal então
gírias de Natal eu falo eu não falo os
pivete eu falo os eu falo os pinta mas é
que é o nome do do Maloka tá ligado que
é o nome do cara que é a gente fala os
guri é diferente tem gente que acha que
precisa de Curitiba acho que eu falo
bate que é no Rio Grande do Sul
também no mesmo lugar todo entendeu ou
quando falam que o meu sotaque não
combina comigo porque Como assim
Paranaense então eu já ouvi muito isso é
tão estranho ver uma preta Paranaense
Curitibana porque eu falo gente
e o Ronaldinho Gaúcho a gente fala e o
Ronaldinho ou seja mais Carioca do que
Gaúcho isso isso eu entendo também a
mesma coisa assim não é a mesma coisa
Lógico que não é é a mesma sabe mas é
aquela parada do tipo
não é não são tantos estados para saber
quais são as capitais está ligado
a gente é péssimo em entender essas
coisas porque que nem eu não sou muito
boa em Geografia nem história Era um
professor que eu não me davam bem na
época história no colégio achava um saco
porque falava dos escravos
eu sempre fui meio Rebelde com isso
também que eu falava para quem falava
dos escravos desse jeito eu falava mas
não tem outro lugar que a gente veio
nasceu da Tábua do Navio Negreiro não
tem outra coisa E aí depois você vê que
tem outra coisa só que a gente aprende
só Pelas nossas famílias Mas por que não
fala no colégio então não vou assistir
essa aula vou sair vou arranjar um
problema com essa professora não me
sinto confortável Então eu tinha essa
rebeldia assim sabe por me sentir
Curitibana deslocada agora nem Curitiba
Curitiba me botou no paredão Brasil me
botou no paredão eu me botei no paredão
e o próprio paredão me botou no paredão
eu não sei o que que eu não sei eu acho
que eu tenho que ser pregada numa cruz
para
ver o povo precisa apedrejar de verdade
é que hoje em dia o apedrejamento o
linchamento Ele é virtual eu não sei se
isso é bom ou ruim porque se fosse
Antigamente eu não estaria nem aqui para
dar entrevista eu teria sido jogada para
os leões
eu tô no processo de parar de me auto
flagelar minha auto sabotar entender que
somos ser humano ah soberba também tá
ligada no Ah eu errei Poxa fiz cagada
que merda minha vida e achar que nada
mais está acontecendo a não ser a
decepção mas o mundo tem tantas outras
coisas que a gente só esse tamanho aqui
sabe para eu entender que assim também a
soberba pode estar relacionado também a
essa falta de compreensão assim não tá
errei mas vamos ver aqui que eu posso
fazer ele na frente ainda mais quando a
gente meio que se
quando a gente entende que a gente
realmente tem que buscar o nosso lugar
no mundo entender porque antes a gente
não tava com o nosso lugar no mundo por
isso que a gente fica meio assim perdido
continuamos E agora onde eu vou antes eu
pensava que eu precisava tipo assim
Ah tá ganhei dinheiro então tipo o que
que eu tô fazendo agora
ah eu quando era novo eu queria que
alguém me ajudasse Então eu tenho que
ajudar as pessoas Ah então é esse Ah
então entendi então tipo tudo que for
para mim tem que ser para mim e mais um
monte de gente também
agradar não para ajudar um monte de
gente então eu criei meio que um
propósito de
sempre que eu se beneficiado um monte de
gente seria beneficiada também então
meio que virou um nortinho para mim
entendeu
encontrar um nortinho um lugar para ir
ah sempre que eu for trabalhar mais 35
pessoas também vão ter suas famílias
beneficiada com um trabalho que o cara
tava num tava sem trabalhar e agora ele
tem um trabalhinho por um tempo e tudo
mais e aí virou meio isso talvez seja
incrível a pessoa encontrar tipo
realmente coisas que beneficia e não só
você como várias outras pessoas como
daquele jeito que já assim cara o
Leonardo Dicaprio eu até falei hoje né
Leonardo DiCaprio se ele não ajudar
Amazônia ele é só um ator de Hollywood
ele não é nada de diferente além de tipo
Brad Pitt tipo
nós vivemos o mundo que precisa de troca
não só material eu digo troca
energética entender fala Poxa da Galera
também [ __ ] total 100% é uma troca a
gente precisa deles eles precisam da
gente e eu tô nesse
quando eles não estão com a gente por
isso que a gente fica tanto decepcionado
porque assim assim fala nossa como é que
vai ser eu vou trabalhar ninguém mais
quer falar comigo ninguém mais quer se
associar a mim como é que fica a minha
equipe aí pedindo desculpa para todo
mundo falando gente eu não vou conseguir
render como eu rende antes porque eu fiz
a cagada
de ter péssimas atitudes e ter montado
na soberba no reality então vocês me
perdoem a hora que tiver melhor eu chamo
vocês vocês não quiseram continuar
comigo eu vou entender e eles não a
gente tá aqui não é na hora do Ouro que
a gente tá junto na hora da isso vai
passar Carol e eu falo porque está com
você na
tá com você até na hora que você tá
subindo é mais fácil do que que tá você
quando você tá no pulso que quando você
tá subindo tá funcionando hoje é 2000
amanhã é 5500 amanhã é 8 depois de
amanhã já é 12 então tá sempre uma
constante então é muito bom estar com a
gente é muito bom estar com essa tá
sempre viajando você tá sempre legal
você tá sempre
curtindo você tá sendo feliz lógico que
é ótimo Tá na minha na minha caminhada
porque assim eu sempre estende a mão eu
ajudei muitas pessoas se eu tenho
acolhimento agora Lembra daquela da
conversa no começo do Se você dá você
recebe eu recebo acolhimento carinho e
respeito porque eu dei muito isso então
se eu tivesse sido uma pessoa realmente
amarga toda ao longo da minha vida eu
não teria recebido acolhimento nenhum
agora eu não teria nem aqui se eu fosse
uma pessoa do mal o público que te
acompanha sabe que eu não estaria aqui
você me chamou não é por
não sinto que você me chamou aqui
sensacionalismo por você não precisa
disso Você não precisa desse tipo de
engajamento e isso é bem nítido nas
coisas que você faz na sua personalidade
então eu aceitei vir porque eu já te
conheço eu sou uma fã eu acompanho seu
trabalho eu admiro muito o a clareza e a
coragem que você teve de expor a sua
depressão na época Me tocou muito porque
foi numa época que eu tinha assim falava
Gente ninguém fala sobre isso direito eu
não falo eu tinha vergonha de falar tá
vendo e aí se eu não falasse
você não quer saber
e aí eu chegasse para você dois barras
que você num corredor de um de uma
emissora e tudo mais a gente tá
conversando e tudo mais você passava por
mim você não ia saber tá ligado que eu
passo que eu passei sim que eu sinto que
eu pensei e tudo mais e aí a gente não
tem a gente não reage às vezes do jeito
que tem que reagir tá ligado eu passei
muito tempo com vergonha de mostrar
minha fragilidade de me expor como fraca
porque tenho essa coisa na minha cabeça
de ser mulher preta para muitas pessoas
é um saco esse assunto de preta preta
imagina para mim que sou preta também eu
acho um saco mas eu reconheço os traumas
mas tem que falar às vezes eu penso a
vida inteira vai ser isso a vida inteira
eu vou ter que ficar falando sofrimento
que é ser uma mulher preta eu expondo
exemplo porque que eu como mulher preta
foi cancelada nessa situação se outra
pessoa branca fez pior ou igual e não
teve esse cancelamento
e ganhou por quê fez e ganhou e ganhou
que teve gente que disse e Fulano
assaltou o condomínio e ele nem parecia
bandido era branquinha assim e ganhou
entendeu E aí não querem que eu pense
que algum problema está relacionado à
questão da negritude eu falo não não é
possível mas porque aí eu começo a
pensar Ah entendi eu como mulher preta
tem que ser quieta submissa e não reagir
eu não posso
opinar nada é sempre
a gente pode ver claramente que rolou
nesse reality agora que tiveram dois
participantes pretos e o público tava
até então não tinha problema nenhum com
eles que é o João e a Camila chamavam de
planta quando eles decidiram ou se
sentiram Na necessidade de expor opinião
ou se defender de alguma situação o
público acabou ah não eles são chatos Ah
já vem lá eles com esse papo de
militância então a verdade é que o preto
ele só serve na sociedade ou na
televisão quando ele tá sofrendo ou
quando ele está calado e submisso comece
a reparar e fazer uma reflexão de todos
os artistas que demonstraram um
pouquinho se não teve gente achando
estranho pega tira a minha cor tira a
cor de outra pessoa pega a mesma atitude
e veja a o peso da reação das pessoas
existe sim um erro eu errei óbvio não tô
justificando nem negando mas existe
também um erro da parte do público em
julgar sempre com mais peso mais mais
acidez quando a personalidade é preta
Entendeu essa pode ser a mais querida de
todas igual tem no reality Ali temos
personalidades pretas queridas sem a
flacidez que eu tive sem essa revolta
mas também estão sendo julgados e a
pauta é porque são negros ou é o cabelo
ou é porque se sentiu dolorido com
alguma coisa
é um saco a mesma coisa que todo mundo
fala toda vez meu filho morreu
meu filho morreu porque morava ali
estudava ali aquele caminhava dessa
forma porque não dava dessa forma e
agressividade da mulher preta porque ela
foi agressiva porque ela tem isso teve
gente também
teve gente que chegou para ti e falou
para ti também tipo assim você tá
continuando o estereótipo da mulher
preta barraqueira
muito triste porque afinal consegue te
ajudar
porque era uma coisa que não era o que
fazer Óbvio que não mas a minha vida eu
aprendi para ser ouvido respeitado era
só no barraco foi o que eu aprendi e
algumas amigas pretas minhas também
então é muito complicado falar desses
temas Muitas pessoas não levam a sério
eles preferem levar mais a sério o ódio
coletivo do que as camadas que me
levaram até atitudes péssimas quando eu
conto alguma coisa né de racismo que
aconteceu perto de mim porque tipo eu
não posso falar sobre uma cena que eu
não passo isso né Isso não vai acontecer
comigo
contra o branco não tem racismo é
conceito talvez com preconceito
preconceito tem antes de conhecer a
pessoa não é o sentido literal da
palavra preconceito que leva a você
falar de racismo pode ser um preconceito
mas o racismo não tem porque a minha
raça nunca passou por tantos anos de
Sofrimento igual
todo mundo passou né então tipo assim
chega para mim o que acontece com
acontece comigo eu falo com Eu tenho um
amigo Robson por exemplo Robson é um
cara que anda comigo e constantemente as
coisas acontecem com ele e
constantemente eu tô junto entendeu
então tipo olha para mim o Robson Diz
para mim tu viu aquele caso de racismo
que aconteceu olha para mim e eu falo
assim
quando eu tenho que tomar atitude eu
tomo atitude porque
Porque se o erro é da minha galera Então
sou eu que tenho que corrigir a minha
galera né Não não é você que tem que
ficar falando que o cara tá errando
porque o cara tá sempre a vida inteira
não vai não vai mudar porque tu tá
falando é o cara vai achar que aquilo
e aí eu vou lá e fala com o cara por
exemplo vamos vamos resolver o problema
do Robson chegar comigo a galera achar
que o Robson é o meu segurança
[ __ ] Robson é grandão o Robson é
altão então é um Robson segurança né
porque ele anda comigo ou Robson
motorista né porque o Robson anda comigo
eu tô lá e fala tudo bom tudo bem aí eu
vou comer e o cara fala e o motorista
não come não aí eu falo assim é
vamos resolver Robson quando a gente
chega em outro lugar eu já chego tudo
bom meu esse aqui é o Robson meu
roteirista entendeu então tipo assim eu
dou meu eu dou meu que eu posso fazer
porque eu não tenho muito o que fazer a
não ser tipo falar para o cara parar de
achar que quem chega comigo e é grande e
é preto é por segurança ou é motorista
entendeu então tipo até aconteceu uma
vez de eu estar com ele no banco e eu
falasse com eu fui sacando dinheiro e
falou Robson vamos comigo lá dentro e
tal Porque eu tenho medo que as pessoas
sei lá sempre ando com alguém Claro E
logicamente você não quer você não olha
a cor da pessoa que anda com você Você
anda com alguém né [ __ ] [ __ ] e aí eu
tô lá com hop você fala assim Robson vou
sacar aqui 5.000 para nós fazer tal
coisa espera aí fica aqui comigo aí eu
vou sacana eu vou dando pro Robson
sacana eu vou dando para o Robson Robson
eu comecei a perceber que quem tá vendo
pela câmera de segurança lá dentro tá
vendo eu sacando e te dando dinheiro
aqui aí eu falei assim Robson eu tô
sendo
preconceituoso eu tô sendo precavido Tá
ligado não tem que eu tô sendo
preconceito
já tá visualizando preconceito e tomando
um cuidado
minha galera não chega perguntando tá
ligado a minha galera é racista porque
se ver você já dando dinheiro acho que
você está sendo assaltado né E alguém
vai pode pensar que também por eu achar
isso eu tô achando ou eu tô sendo
preconceituoso por achar ou eu tô sendo
compaixão com meu amigo porque eu tenho
medo pelo meu amigo tá ligado porque eu
sei porque meu amigo já foi tipo já foi
autuado porque ele entrou na farmácia e
ele não coreografou o movimento que ele
ia fazer para ver um produto entendeu
e chegando perto de mim as coisas porque
o cara vê na câmera e vai lá atrás de
mim então eu pego você mostra o produto
deixa bem e eu boto ele lá em cima de
novo tá ligado então tipo assim pô eu
vejo um problema do meu amigo todo dia
todo dia todo dia todo dia todo dia não
Meus amigos chegam atrasados e OK aí
chega o meu amigo atrasado e ele é
folgado porque ele chegou ele é muito
folgado porque ele demorou e ele e se
aquilo eu falo gente mas todo mundo
demorou cara aí a galera escolhe ele
para ser o folgado escolhe ele para ser
o cara tá ligado Então eu falo com ele
assim Robson às vezes eu tinha vontade
de falar tudo que eu tenho vontade para
falar mas eu não tenho como chegar no
teu lugar e falar entendeu porque você é
o cara que tem que falar mas às vezes eu
tenho vontade de falar assim gente dá um
time com o Robson mas fale porque às
vezes é só de branco para branco que o
anti-racismo Funciona porque quando é um
preto falando pessoa como se fosse algo
chato as pessoas o branco geralmente tem
preguiça
sempre fala que ele sempre fala ai que
chatice esse papo de novo e quando a
gente fala da amplitude do branco não é
da pele branca ou de você branco é de um
sistema branco e quando o branco racista
fala do preto ele não fala nem do
sistema negro porque não é como se não
existisse na sociedade e aí ele fala do
indivíduo do preto do Preto esse da
pessoa é preto que nem no meu caso já
tinha que ser preto entrou no reality
cagou com tudo só os preto que fazem
cagada como se branco não fizesse cagada
então tanto Preto Quanto o branco estão
sujeitos a errar e assumiu o erro
existem vários tipos de pessoas existe
aquela pessoa que erra assume existe
aqui nunca erra mas quando errar vai dar
um fim na própria vida porque tá montado
na sua beba e acredita que não pode
errar é soberania por isso que eu falo
que desistir não é não combina comigo
nem com meu look porque quando você
desiste de uma coisa que deu errado é
sinal de que você não tá para evolução
Desde quando a evolução ela tá ligada à
perfeição
entendeu Então você começa a reparar
umas coisas quando tem o anti-racismo
É só uma questão de tipo e o que é o
movimento o movimento anti-racista ele é
o que na verdade é você ir na internet
um belo dia no mês hashtag blacklines
racismo E aí numa oportunidade que você
tem para definir para acabar com artista
Preto você vai lá e falar mas é porque é
preto não pode levar rajadão pode a
questão é qual é o nível intensidade
desse rajadão que você tá dando para
esse para essa figura Não tô dizendo que
eu não merecia ser linchada merecia ser
punida dentro do game né não agredir
ninguém fisicamente não não cometi
nenhum crime grave não tem essa
intensidade Então porque será que não tá
ligado ao ódio encubado da mulher preta
se dizer tão poderosa ela sai tombando
tudo
uma boa carreira porque quantas
histórias de mulheres mulheres pretas na
música A gente tem que sofrer um
cancelamento
tem várias entendeu tiveram artistas
pretas aqui do Brasil que contribuíram
para o meu linchamento artistas essas
que também já foram linchadas e
canceladas
então você vê que o negócio ele não vai
artista Preta se fala como uma mulher
uma artista preta que é constantemente
cancelada e linchada na internet por ter
a vida vivendo do jeito que quer por
cantar a música que canta ela vai ela
ajuda no linchamento
inventa situações E aí depois de uma
semana ou duas você vê essa pessoa sendo
cancelada de novo ou tendo alguma ação
na justiça que não foi legal você vê que
o mundo ele gira
E essas mesmas pessoas pretas que
cancelam pessoas pretas que falam em
nome de Deus estão fazendo atitudes
piores do que aquela personagem que eu
já não gosto nunca gostei que a Carol
com cá dentro do BBB como acontecia com
pessoas que chegavam para mim e falava
você viu aí eu falava não Não assisto
não mas eu vejo no Twitter e tal então
eu vi uma coisa lá lá lá aí eu fui
péssima e a pessoa é isso e a pessoa
aquilo e aí existe ela é podre mas é o
ser humano por dentro já tá apodrecido e
eu lembrando de Atos que a pessoa fez tá
ligado Tipo assim cara então tá caindo
os pedaços de podre E aí aproveitando já
quem tá falando de reality né porque eu
vi lá dentro né nos looks nas conversas
e tudo mais se você gostava de dar uma
parada mais espacial
a mais Universal e mais Alienígena
E aí sabe o que aconteceu comigo esses
dias eu tava na minha varanda E aí eu
tava pensando assim [ __ ] eu ia ser
muito legal se eu visse um OVNI agora e
aí quando deu alguns minutos o que eu
falei isso eu vi um OVNI
gente
gostar de Karol com kg gente não é
possível
que saiu teve um
ele anda de lado
[Música]
Nossa e a fluorescente
olha olha
não faz isso
parou parou
Será que ele sabia que estava olhando
ele
meu Deus é sempre nesses lugares que
eles aparecem
ninguém levanta Drone esse horário em
Barueri e não tem Drone com luz assim
não existe E aí eu mandei isso e meu
amigo me mandou esse
gente Eu Tô chocada eu quero ver ao vivo
também
meu Deus são dois meu amigo falou assim
ó olha olha vai vazar bem rápido
aí o cara falou assim ó você tá
apertando outro ângulo meu
olha
olha outro um dois três eram três que
lindo
olha a cor meu Deus do céu meu Deus e o
povo me chamando de louca e aí eu tava
te vendo lá no big brother
e aí eu vi esses dias tu já viu alguma
coisa Não não que eu saiba mas tem
vontade de ver eu tenho vontade de ver
eu creio neles e quando eu falava assim
no dia que eu ganhei a liderança eu
ficava assim
é desde o dia que eu acordei eu falava
eu sou a nova líder sou a nova
Leda Deus valem comigo e eu ficava
cimento isso eu falava vai para cá E aí
eu viajei porque como eu tenho toque eu
tenho toque real que nem da hora que a
gente tá conversando aqui eu já tava
olhando Como que tá as fitinhas ali e aí
falta uma né ali porque tá dois dois aí
não tem a segunda ali
ó todos esse e olha a última Olha a
última Olha lá só tem uma Eu Tava
incomodado com esse que só falta uma
também e eu falo com você olhando ali e
aí eu vejo que tá faltando ali eu fico
na minha cabeça eu imaginei eu tirando
de algum lugar botando eu fico assim e
aí eu tava assim na prova e eu falava
essas Mangueiras aí deixa eu ver essas
Mangueiras
falei nossa tem umas que estão
conectadas outras não tão a viagem da
louca no rolê né e eu ah vou no número
21 a 21 já foi vou no 17
foi 17 eu ai gente sabe como que eu vi
eu vi que a mangueira tava conectada e
isso era uma coisa que eu achei o quem
libera a água na prova é a produção não
é aquela mangueira que tá ali aquilo é
um cenário
e eu na minha cabeça por ter notado se
eu notar alguma coisa fora do encaixe eu
já nota que eu já vejo rápido se eu tô
assistindo filme eu vejo
problema com continuidade eu vejo tudo
isso então ali a minha cabeça imagino eu
tinha que me levar do paredão eu ficava
assim
esse era para me livrar do paredão né
que era o bate-volta aí eu olhei e
comentei não a mangueira a mangueira não
tava eu aqui fora o povo nossa ela
trapaceou porque a Globo Então imagina a
cabeça da produção desse programa com a
minha loucura lá dentro toda hora tudo
que eu falava parecia que eu tinha
recebido
e eu não recebi eu não recebi mesmo não
recebi se eu tivesse recebido essa
altura no ponto da Loucura eu já falei
não recebi mesmo
mas eu falava obrigada Deus obrigada ETs
E aí Me perguntaram porque os ets tem
Deus mas você que acredita em Deus
acredita em ET eu falo sim
Qual o problema Eu acho que o ET tá
ligado a Deus também porque não e também
se ele não tá na terra tipo a morada
dele não é aqui é tipo no céu ele é
extraterrestre não é uma coisa muito
diferente ele só só tá um pouco longe
daqui não quer dizer que ele tem a
mãozinha pequena e é verde assim ele é
extra né Porque pô eu ouvi dizer que
eles são parecidos com a gente os ets
para saber eu ouvi dizer mas é que eu vi
os ufólogos alguns vídeos ufólogos
falando isso que para saber quem são
eles eles são extremamente educados já
sei que eu não sou ET Porque na casa foi
extremamente sem educação
bem mal educada mas os ets eles são bem
educados
Carol obrigado por você ter vindo aqui
conversar comigo e e como você falou
tipo expor suas fragilidades né porque
quando você vai no lugar você ou você
chega antes e fala assim não quero falar
sobre tal coisa ou você chega lá e fala
assim para você mesmo né É vamos lá
conversar e vamos ver o que que é e você
vê aqui e você vai bater um papo é eu
sou assim o negócio é encarar de frente
obrigada obrigada por esse espaço pela
pela acolhimento pela empatia
às vezes às vezes a gente tá fazendo a
praticando a tal da empatia sem nem
saber né no caso né porque
o interesse meu tem também Lógico né eu
tô começando com você nós estamos juntos
aqui no mesmo lugar eu sei que isso vai
gerar alguma coisa galera vai assistir E
aí aproveitando isso a gente tem que
aproveitar e falar o que a gente tem
vontade de falar porque eu também tinha
vontade de expor minha opinião sobre
esse assunto eu não curto muito que todo
mundo odeia alguém tá ligado que todo
mundo se junte minhas atitudes foram
odiáveis mas eu não sou uma pessoa do
mal eu não eu não mereço ser odiada
minhas atitudes sim eu entendo o que que
você tá dizendo eu entendo que você tá
dizendo
é ser incompreendido faz parte da vida
do artista é bom a gente botar na cabeça
isso porque sem compreendido faz parte
da nossa vida a gente fala qual é a
senha do wi-fi teve empresário meu que
disse para eu não postar porque Faria
mal minha carreira Porque fala de
internet porque eu mexo com internet
qual seria a senha irmão
eu tô criativa agora minha cabeça tá
dizendo que sim então eu vou nessa e
tudo mais então tipo a gente sabe que a
cabeça do artista
é muito doida é e a gente nasceu para
ser uma coisa realmente diferente não
adianta a gente dizer que a gente quer
ser um civil normal e trabalhar num
lugar comum que a gente não consegue a
gente não consegue a gente gosta de se
expressar a gente vai estar naquele
trabalho a gente vai falar assim vai
cantar um rap que nem você falou você
vai dar um reto Olha a galera vai falar
porque você não faz rap porque aquele
celular do seu artista está espremendo
tanto que tá saindo assim ele tá
transbordando já então é nosso destino
isso aqui não tem muito entendeu não tem
muito obrigado por você ter vindo aqui
você ser Eu que agradeço você ser real
comigo obrigado obrigada
alguém aí que tá assistindo de alguma
forma que é para isso quem tá aqui
conversando a gente vem conversar passa
entendeu que ela me entendesse também
tá ligado
todo mundo mais uma vez
e vamos nessa vamos seguir qualquer
coisa me bota no seu coração qualquer
coisa me faz uma oração
tamo junto se você gostou não esquece de
clicar em gostei comentar aqui embaixo
quem você quer ver por aqui
algum dia e o que que você tirou de
legal desse lugar essa conversa aqui tá
se você quiser comentar aí deixar sua
análise a gente já sabe que você é um
psicólogo e você é um terapeuta você
sabe de tudo então fique tranquilo deixa
sua opinião aí que a gente vai ler todas
as 15 mil e tantas que tiver É isso aí
não esquece de seguir Carol com K lá
seguir e ver os novos trabalhos os meus
trabalhos novos Também meus novos
projetos Curte lá me segue tamo junto é
nós respeita
[Música]
[Risadas]